Sofort eine Vermittlung zum Fritz Server aufbauen. Verbindung hergestellt. Soll das aktuelle Programm abgewählt werden? Kabel Salat ist gesund.
Zugriff gewährt zum aktuellen Programm.
H-Slang Na, herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio lange nicht mehr gehört. Ausnahmsweise mal wieder völlig normal am letzten Mittwoch des Monats. Nämlich Chaos Radio der Computer Blumen bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny am Mikrofon.
Hallo.
Wer diese Sendung schonmal gehört hat, der weiß das zu Beginn, wenn die außer mir noch anderen vier Leute hier im Studio die Mikros testen, wenn mal das Geheule groß ist, wenn es nicht klappt.
Von rechts nach rechts oder von rechts nach links?
Von mir aus gesehen von links nach rechts.
Wie es von dir aus gesehen hat.
Genau, und der Steini grüßt euch auch alle wieder.
Der Mike sagt hallo und Andreas ist auch dabei.
Also Mike, alles alte Bekannte, aber Mike, du warst einmal hier schon, oder? Warum bist du heute dann ausgerechnet, wofür bist du Experte, dass wir dich heute mitgeschleppt haben?
Ich finde, ich bin mit diesem akronymen Anfall zufrieden.
Ja, Bananen. Also Schokobananen, das ist auch ein echter Expert.
So viel bricht die Sendung fällt ins Wasser, weil da Bauchschmerzen trinken werden.
Mir ist so schlecht.
Mike ist fasziniert von Akronymen. Dann sind wir auch schon mittendrin im Thema.
Wir sind alle keine Experten.
Für alles Experten sowieso. Oder eben für gar nichts, wie das halt so ist. Bevor wir allerdings in das richtige Thema, das heute in den Chaosradios einsteigen, nämlich Internet eine Sprache für sich, oder was ist die Überschrift, wie sollte man das am besten kurz sagen, oder nennen wir es einfach Loll, oder...
Ja oder Rotfl, also das ist ja eher die Ausgabe.
Wir werden uns mit der internetspezifischen Sprache beschäftigen, mit dem was da so als Abkürzung...
Es geht hier um Hacker.
Es geht hier um Hacker. Wieso um Hacker? Internet ist etwas, was sehr viel später kam.
Aber wenn ich in Chat bin, dann sind das nur Internetbenutzer?
Nein. Oder? Ja, was soll man dazu sagen, also auch Chats gibt es schon länger als das Internet. Das sind halt alles keine Traditionen, die jetzt irgendwie ursächlich aus dem Internet kommen. Sicherlich hat das Internet dazu beigetragen, das alles zu verstärken.
Moment mal, du meinst also Abkürzungen, die im Netz benutzt werden, gab es schon bevor es das Internet gab?
Nein, Abkürzungen, die im Fernsehen benutzt wird, gab es aber sicherlich auch schon irgendwo vorher. Also ich meine, auch das Fernsehen hat da genauso wenig die Definitionskraft wie das Internet.
Also du meinst, dass bestimmte Abkürzungen nicht durch das Netz kreiert worden sind, sondern es schon vorher gab?
Ich möchte nur feststellen, dass wir über Hacker-Jaggungen reden wollen. Also es geht um die Art und Alte wie diese Leute.
Den Unterschied kannst du mir nachher nochmal klar machen.
Wir haben ja jetzt drei Stunden Zeit.
Damit ich das endlich begreife und vielleicht mit mir auch einige andere.
Wie war das mit der Hintergrundmusik?
Die kommt jetzt gleich, ich wollte nur noch sagen, dass wir vorher natürlich erstmal ein bisschen einen kleinen Rückblick machen. Zum letzten Chaos Communication Congress, das gleich. Herzlich willkommen nochmal an alle da draußen, die uns auch hören können. Wenn ihr nicht in Frizz Empfangs weiter seid über Real Audio, die Adresse ist www.frizz.de live.ram Nur schade, dass die das jetzt alle nicht hören können, die Frizz nicht empfangen können. Nö, aber im Chat kann man das ja weitergeben.
Live ist die Sache auch im CCC Chat unter tellnet www.ccc.de nicht http www.ccc.de, ihr wisst schon. Dort kann man dann auch gleich die Sprachankrobatik, über die wir reden, fleißig betreiben. Es hängen auch schon eine Menge Leute rum, die irgendwie das Jargon-File unter dem Arm haben.
Und wenn das alles viel zu kompliziert ist, der weist seinen Webbrowser einfach in Richtung www.ccc.de oder www.ac.org.uk. So soll es sein, wenn der Chaos Computer Club schon mal im Radio ist mit eigener Sendung, dann doch bitte auch ein paar Sätze zum Chaos Communication Congress. Der fand nämlich letztes Jahr statt, ist aber trotzdem nicht so lange her. 27. bis 29. Dezember war es in Berlin, in Berlin ausnahmsweise, weil er vorher die ganzen Jahre in Hamburg war.
Na ja, zwangsläufigerweise würde ich eher sagen. Bis auf einmal.
Er war schon einmal auch in Berlin, aber jetzt war er in Berlin aus dem ganz wichtigen Grund, weil das Eitelstädter Bürgerhaus viel zu klein geworden ist und weil wir hier in Berlin eine Location gefunden haben, die sowas von dir ideal passend dafür ist. Wie viele Leute waren da in den drei Tagen?
Oh, also es waren...
Viele.
Ja, viele. Also es waren irgendwie über 2000 Leute da.
Insgesamt an den drei Tagen?
Ja.
Genau, genau.
Im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Für die Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, was da eigentlich passiert, ist ja das Beeindruckendste tatsächlich das Hackcenter jedes Mal. Also für mich immer noch. Ich finde es immer grandios, wenn man in einen riesen Raum reinkommt, wo Leute die unterschiedlichsten Computer aufgebaut haben. Also wirklich, du hast alles gesehen. Von irgendwelchen kleinen Taschen-PCs, den neuesten Modellen. Das ist auch so eine hübsche Modell-Schau. Man kann sich da endlich mal in Ruhe angucken, was es auf dem Markt gibt. Also wirklich kleine Handhelds sozusagen, bis hin zu riesigen alten Kisten. Dann steht zwischendurch immer mal wieder so ein ganz kleiner alter McIntosh-Würfel. C64 habe ich gesehen. C64 habe ich auch gesehen.
Selbstbaugrahmen, es gab einmal wieder alles.
Offen, natürlich die meisten Rechner offen, klar, weil man muss ja ständig ran. Leute rennen mit Platinen durch die Gegend und mit Festplatten und natürlich mit Ethernet-Kabeln. Denn die ganzen Rechner müssen natürlich vernetzt werden. Und was machen die denn da bitte alle?
Na die hacken.
Deswegen hat das ja auch Hack-Center.
Gut, dann haben wir das ja abgehackt. Machen wir weiter mit dem Thema.
Nee, da sind wir in gewisser Hinsicht sehr beim Thema der Sprache, weil das ist einfach einer von 30 verschiedenen möglichen Deutungen des Wortes hacken, die einfach genau ins Schwarze treffen. Das ist das, was sie da tun. Sie haben da gesessen und haben sich einfach mit ihren Maschinen auseinandergesetzt. Also einfach dieses diese Kontemplative beschäftigen mit diesem Medium oder mit dieser Maschine und das einfach das verstehen wollen und das irgendwie Grenzen überwinden wollen. Das ist das, was das Wort Hack in sich trägt. Und deswegen ist das eben auch das Hack-Center. Weil das einfach das Zentrum der ganzen Hackerei ist auf dem Kongress.
Und das heißt nicht, dass man sagt, sie setzen sich mit ihren Maschinen auseinander. Das heißt nicht, dass sie sich nur damit auseinandersetzen, sondern da findet ihr auch eine Menge verbale Kommunikation untereinander statt. Also alle sind am plaudern, labern, dann stellt sie stet mal rum, irgendwie trinken Kaffee zusammen, tauscht neuesten Informationen an.
Für die Außenstehenden nicht immer verständlich, worum die Gespräche sich so drehen.
Und da sind wir dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder mittendrin im Jargon, nämlich im Slang. Aber das Hackcenter ist ja nicht das einzige, was da stattfindet. Also man trifft sich da ja nicht nur, um seinen Rechner an den nächsten zu schließen, und gemeinsam zu gucken, ob man ein nettes Programm ausprobieren kann oder solche Geschichten, sondern es finden Workshops statt, es gibt einige Extra-Veranstaltungen. Und dann hatte ich auch so Gäste in anderen Räumen noch. Also gab es irgendwie so eine Radiostation oder sowas war auch da?
Eine Radiostation ist nicht die richtige Bezahlung. Ja, es gab ein Hackcenter Radio, was im Hackcenter auf dem Netz Peril Audio einfach live Musik gemacht hat. Die haben irgendwie auch von ihren MP3s gespielt und Sound gemacht und talala und aber auch Kommentare gemacht. Ich hab leider den Mitschnitt noch nicht erreicht, deswegen weiß ich nicht genau, was da passiert ist. Auf jeden Fall war relativ viel Aktivität. Grundsätzlich teilt sich der Kongress immer in die Vortragsräume auf und eben das Hackcenter und sonstige Vergnügungen, wie die Schlossöffner, die dort ihre deutschen Meisterschaften wieder abgehalten haben und Schlossöffnungs-Blockshops durchgezogen haben.
Da muss ich dich ganz kurz unterbrechen. Das wollte ich mir angucken, habe ich aber verpasst. Schloss öffnen im Sinne von, muss man dazu sagen, also nicht digitale Schlösser öffnen, sondern ganz analoge Türschlösser öffnen.
Genau, richtige Metall-Sicherheitsschlösser.
Meisterschaft mit verschiedenen Sportarten.
Bei der letzten Ausscheidung standen hier also vorne auf der Bühne zehn Leute.
Jeder hatte das Schloss des Nachbarn in der Hand und musste das öffnen. Muss also erst sein eigenes Schloss öffnen, dann das Schloss des Nachbarn.
Und dafür hat man immer eine Minute Zeit.
Das geht dann so, dass es dann auf drei losgeht. Und der, der es als erstes offen hat, sagt hier. Und das war so faszinierend. Da zählt der eins, zwei, drei, vier, vier. Und so haben sie da reihenweise in 0, 0 Sekunden diese ganzen Schlösser aufgemacht. Hab ich dann auch gestaunt. Die arbeiten mit Lidrichen. Die arbeiten mit Lockpick-Tools. Das sind so kleine, flach geklopfte Fahrradspeichen oder auch professionelle Tools.
Als E-Pick dann irgendwie mit Elektro.
Genau, sowas gibt es auch, aber das ist dann schon nicht mehr richtig sportlich.
Na ja, es ist nicht wirklich einfacher, da mit dem Schloss aufzumachen als mit den Handtools. Ja, und anders.
Und das ist auch sportlich.
Ich meine auch Formel 1 ist halt sportlich. Na gut, da kann man sich jetzt über... Da kann man sich streiten, aber das ist auf jeden Fall akribische Auseinandersetzung mit dem Problem irgendwie schneller sein.
Aber trotzdem war das nicht...
Ich denke, wir sollten das nicht vertiefen. Das war nicht der Kongress. Das ist ein Side-Projekt. Das war eines der Side-Projekte da. Es ging da schon mehr darum, dass die europäische Hacker-Community sich da über Themen auseinandergesetzt hat, die im letzten Jahr akut waren oder jetzt im kommenden Jahr akut werden. Da kann man sicher im Netz auch noch viel zu lesen, was da alles gelaufen ist. Das führt sicher viel zu weit, wenn man da jetzt...
Vielleicht führt es nicht.
Vielleicht die ein, zwei Hauptthemen, die den Kongress an allen drei Tagen beherrscht haben. Worüber hat man am meisten diskutiert, worüber hat man am meisten geredet und bei welchen Workshops gab es den größten Ansturm?
Also die Workshops waren eigentlich alle überlaufen. Wir mussten dann auch teilweise wieder umschichten, weil manche so überlaufen waren, dass wir auf jeden Fall in die große Aula mussten. Dass wir die größte Rolle haben, das war ein Vorteil. Es sind auch wiederholt worden teilweise, gerade diese TTIP-Einführungsgeschichten. Die Meta-Themen, also ich meine, welche Themen da alle beschäftigt wurden, welche Themen da alle so gerollt wurden, das kann man nicht sagen. Da sind Millionen Themen rumgegangen. Aber was sicherlich einen schweren Eindruck hinterlassen hat, auf diesem Kongress waren die beiden Hauptthemen der ersten beiden Tage auf der einen Seite das Schicksal von Tron und am zweiten Tag fast die gleiche Geschichte, nur zehn Jahre älter, das Schicksal von Karl Koch, das jetzt verfilmt worden ist, mit dem Film, den sich jetzt jeder im Kino angucken kann, sicherlich einige auch schon gesehen haben. Dazu wollten wir uns äußern, das haben wir auf dem Kongress getan. Und darüber hinaus gab es ja auch diverse Kultur zu sehen. Es waren einfach viele interessante Leute da. Und aus unserer Sicht ist der Kongress sehr positiv verlaufen.
Gibt es eigentlich bei so einer, wenn ja doch eine ganze Menge an Leuten, die für zum Beispiel bestimmte Firmen durchaus auch ein interessantes Zielpublikum wären, kommen Firmen auf euch zu eigentlich mit dem Kongress inzwischen und sagen, hey, wir könnten doch da, weiß nicht, ein bisschen sponsern mit unseren Jeanshosen oder mit unserem Softdrink oder irgendwie so einer Geschichten. Passiert sowas schon oder seid ihr schon noch?
Na ja, so schlimm ist es noch nicht, aber sie sind schon, also wir wollen uns ja eigentlich auch gar nicht sponsern lassen. Also wir laufen da nicht raus und machen die Hand auf. Wir hängen da auch keine Plakate auf irgendwie in der Regel. Sicherlich erfahren wir Unterstützung, aber wir machen diese Unterstützung halt ohne da jetzt groß rauszuschreien. Also wer uns unterstützt, das spricht sich schon rum.
Das Sponsoring läuft dann eher auf eine subtile Art. Da bekommt man die Dinge, mit denen man da rumspielt, halt von der Firma, die sie herstellt und die fragen da nicht, wollen aber auch keine Werbung dafür, das reicht denen, dass es einfach da ist. Und das ist wahrscheinlich dann insofern eine viel bessere Werbung, als wenn sie die riesen Plakate aufhält.
Auf jeden Fall.
Was ist denn mit der Polizei?
Die haben einen Workshop gemacht.
So weit sind sie noch nicht, aber ich meine, sie waren allein schon deshalb da, weil auch gerade da in einem Mordfall ermittelt wird. Und natürlich ist die Polizei auch immer da bei solchen Treffen. Die Polizei war dann halt irgendwie nochmal besonders da, weil ein Kid im Hackcenter auf die tolle Idee gekommen ist, da müsst ihr jetzt mal vom Kongress aus irgendwie da die Maschinen aufmachen, irgendwo in Bremerhaven so ein Provider bisschen drin rumgebohrt. Das fanden die halt irgendwie gar nicht so lustig und haben gleich Strafanzeige erstattet, was dann dazu führte, dass irgendwie das LKA, irgendwie die Berlin-Abteilung Computer betrug, die komplett aufgelaufen ist. Acht Leute, dicke Truppe, gar nicht wussten, wo sie da eigentlich aufschlagen. Und dann auch erstmal in die Stech gestaunt haben und dann später halt zu sehen, dass es ziemlich mühsig ist, in diesem ganzen Hackerhaufen da sich irgendwie eine Alpiatrasse rauszusuchen.
Die wollten dann tatsächlich jemanden verhaften, da kamen sie dann an den Platz und da steckte... Festschnehmen. Ja, da lag, Entschuldigung, Festschnehmen natürlich.
Dann lag da das Kabel rum. Ja, und der Mensch, der war dann wohl schon weg.
Klingt ja jetzt auch alles super lustig, aber an sich her sowieso eine etwas bekloppte Idee, oder? Direkt vom Chaos Communication Congress irgendwie dann um einen Provider anzugreifen.
Na ja, also ich meine, man muss das ja auch so sehen. Wann haben die Leute schon mal irgendwie zwei Megabit Internet und so viel Austausch, um auf neue Ideen zu kommen?
Letzten Endes. Natürlich wird gehackt.
Ich meine, die machen da auch nichts anderes, als irgendwie sie dann zu Hause auch schon vorher und nachher getan haben. Nur, dass es sich dann halt irgendwie vertausendfacht, weil einfach so viele an einem Ort sind. Also es ist nicht bekloppter, als das von zu Hause auszumachen.
Es ist jeder seines Glückes schmied. Und je nachdem, wie gut er sich schützt, wie er sich schützt, davor erkannt zu werden, so leicht ist es dann auch ihn zu erkennen. Und da hatten sich halt ein paar besonders bekloppte gar nicht geschützt. Und das ist dann halt ein bisschen zu wenig.
Es sind halt alle Methoden angewandt worden, die man so anwendet. Alles, was man halt so ausprobiert. Und wenn halt ganz viele Leute das, was man mal ausprobiert, auf einmal ausprobieren, dann fällt das natürlich auf, wenn da massig Portscans gefahren werden auf irgendwelche Server, um mal zu gucken, was da so für Dienste laufen. Gut, mich wirft das nicht aus den Pantinen, weil ich meine, natürlich. So ist das Internet, so ist es gebaut worden. Danach haben alle geschrien, jetzt ist es da, jetzt sollen sie gefälligst auch akzeptieren, was die Konsequenzen daraus sind. Wir haben ihnen ja lang genug erzählt, auf was sie sich da einlassen. Glaubt hat uns ja eh keiner. Dann soll sie sich jetzt nicht aufregen, wenn die Kids feststellen, ohne neue Technologie, die die Welt revolutioniert, dann gucken wir uns die doch mal an. Mit meinen Telefonen beschäftigt man sich ja dann auch mehr als eine Stunde in seinem Leben mit. Und so ist es mit dem Internet auch.
Gleich gibt es mehr Chaos Radio, nach einem Kurz-Info.
Wenn Fritz im Raumanger mündet, dann 100, 1.
Personal, Personal, Personal, Personal.
Die Berliner SPD hat Umweltdesignator Strider zum neuen Landesvorsitzenden gewählt.
Er rief die Partei zur Geschlossenheit auf, um die große Koalition abzulösen.
Strider war vom SPD-Schlitzenkandidaten Momper vorgeschlagen worden, als Ziel gaben beide an, nach der Abgeordneten-Hauswahl im Oktober einen rot-grünen Senat bilden zu wollen. Abstimmung, das Amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen US-Präsident Clinton geht weiter. Der US-Senat beschloss die Vernehmung von Zeugen. Die republikanische Mehrheit lud unter anderem Monika Lewinsky zu einer Befragung vor. Erklärung, Bundesumweltminister Trittin hat sein Vorgehen in der Atompolitik verteidigt. Im Bundestag wandte er sich gegen den Vorwurf, die rechtlichen Folgen eines Ausstiegs nicht zu beachten. Trittin sagte, die Regierung liege Werte auf einen Konsens mit der Industrie, aber das Ende der Atomkraft sei beschlossen. Unfall. Vor der Nordseeinsel Norderney sind zwei Tornadoflugzeuge der Bundeswehr zusammengestoßen und ins Meer gestürzt. Zwei Besatzungsmitglieder wurden verletzt geborgen, zwar Piloten werden noch vermisst. Vorfall.
Im Jemen sind erneut mehrere Deutsche versteckt worden.
Es handelt sich offenbar um eine Entwicklungshelferin und ihre Familie. Das auslartige Amt erklärte, man habe noch keinen Kontakt mit den Entführern.
In dieser Nacht zeitweise Schneefall.
Die Temperaturen liegen zwischen 0 und minus 2 Grad. Morgen dann bedeckt und im Tagesverlauf Schnee oder Schnee, Regen.
Temperaturen dann ein bis vier Tage. Verkehr.
Wir haben, wenn ab den Meldungen, weiterhin eine gute Fahrt.
Das war Matthias Karkoff mit dem Fritz-Korps-Info.
Fritz präsentiert Sie Beat Attack. Die Djames legen auf. Mit Eva Kasall aus Tresor und Discount Berlin und Fengari von Jetfruit. Samstag, 30. Januar, im Basement Elsterwerder.
Ich denke, einen kleinen Überblick zum Chaos Communication Kongress. Im vergangenen Dezember haben wir gegeben, oder?
Ja, ich hoffe doch.
Also, da gibt es so viel zu erzählen, irgendwie das kann man so recht nicht zusammenfragen.
Da findet man auch sicher noch ein bisschen...
Es gibt eine Dokumentation im Netz unter www.cccde.com/kongress98undda sind so die Transkriptionen, da gibt es auch noch ein paar mp3 Files von einigen Vorträgen, die dort gehalten wurden. Das sind aber nicht alle, aber da kommen vielleicht noch welche dazu.
Wir arbeiten dran.
Wir sind gerade mp3-mäßig, haben mit unseren Versprechungen in den letzten Jahren etwas näher gekommen. Es war auf dem Kongress schon verfügbar ein relativ großes Chaosradio-Archiv. Alle Sendungen, die uns von Hörern zugeschickt wurden, auf Tapes und so haben wir jetzt digitalisiert. Die werden in den nächsten Tagen, legt uns nicht fest, auf FTP, ZDT, CDE verfügbar sein. Und wie groß ist denn so ein MP3 von der Sendung? Na, wir haben also in einer guten Qualität, wir haben alles in einer guten und in einer geringen Qualität gemacht. Die gute war irgendwie 50 Megabit. 150?
150 MB.
Doch.
Na aber hallo. I can show it to you, man.
Also wenn du kannst irgendwie...
Und die kleine war 30 oder so.
Also 30 geht ja.
Jaja, das geht schon. Hier die Audio-Dinger sind auch ganz gut. Ich meine, alles nur eine Frage der Zeit. Wir hatten irgendwie nicht die Zeit. Aber wir haben es zumindest vor dem Kongress noch geschafft und es auch ganz ordentlich kopiert worden.
Aber für alle, die der Kongress mehr und mehr interessiert, die müssen einfach beim nächsten Mal kommen. Richtig. wieder in Berlin wahrscheinlich.
Tatsächlich, ja?
Es sieht so aus, ja.
Also der größte Kritiker des Standorts Berlin sagte zur Abschlussveranstaltung, bin ich froh, dass ich mich nicht durchgesetzt habe.
Das ist doch schön.
Wer war denn das? War der schon mal hier? Ahja, ich hab jetzt jemanden im Kopf gehabt.
Aber dann war er jetzt nicht. Okay. Bevor wir mit dem Hacker-Jogger, Hacker-Slang anfangen, gibt es noch ein anderes Stichwort? Ja, genau, Andreas, dein Stichwort würde ich sagen.
Wir haben gerade Spaß am Gerät, alle zusammen ein bisschen. Das Stichwort lautet nämlich RC5. Es gibt schon seit einiger Zeit verschiedene Ausschreibungen der Firma RSA Data Security und zwar geht es darum, Schlüssel zu brechen zu Verschlüsselungsverfahren. Es ist also ein Preisgeld aufgesetzt. Es gibt Verschlüsselte und Nachricht und dieselbe Nachricht noch mal entschlüsselt und man soll den Schlüssel finden dazu. Der Schlüssel hat verschiedene Längen. Gegenlos mit 40 Bit, 48 Bit und so weiter und so fort. Ziel der Aktion ist zu zeigen, dass die Schlüssellängen, die derzeit exportiert werden dürfen, aus den USA zum Beispiel zu kurz sind. Dass das, was in den Netzgebversionen, die man sich hier zuglern herunterladen kann, an Sicherheit drin ist, zu wenig ist. Und mittlerweile sind mehrfach die Test-Challenges gelöst worden. In immer kürzeren Abständen. Beim ersten Mal hat es ein Dreivierteljahr gedauert. Da haben sich Leute über das Internet zusammengeschlossen.
Das sogenannte distributed.net.
Kann man einen kleinen downloaden, von dem werden die Aufgaben an alle anderen Rechner verteilt. Es hat sich viele Leute zusammengefunden, dreiviertel Jahr hat es gedauert, bis DESS mit 56-Wit-Schlüssel-Länge zum ersten Mal geknackt wurde. Dann zwischendurch gab es einmal die zweite Test-Challenge. Da hat dieses Team nicht so gut abgeschnitten. Da hat eine Maschine gewonnen, die dafür gebaut wurde, extra zu diesem Zweck. Und beim dritten Mal haben sie dann die Maschine mit in das Team reingenommen. Und jetzt wurde DESS in 22 Stunden geknackt. Also in 56-Wit-Schlüssel in 22 Stunden. Von dem noch vor zwei Jahren. Die Amerikaner behaupten, es sei alles völlig sicher. Man könnte es überhaupt gar nicht entschlüsseln. Und deswegen durfte man das auch exportieren.
Und wäre gar nicht so toll.
Na ja, kurze Rede langer Sinn auf jeden Fall. Gibt es jetzt noch den RC-5-64-Contest, wo ein 64-Wit-Schlüssel von RC-5 geknackt werden soll. Und man kann dabei Teams bilden. Es geht natürlich wie immer darum, der Schnellste zu sein, die meisten Keys zu knacken, ganz oben in der Liste zu stehen. Und deswegen...
Da huscht ein Lachende über sein Gesicht.
Es ist doch so. Es ist eine tolle Sache. Und man fühlt sich gut, wenn man das das erste Mal macht. Aber spätestens ab dem dritten Tag sitzt man in einem Listing. Wo sind wir denn nachher?
Welcher Platz?
Wo auf der 10 nach vorne? Und deswegen haben wir uns im CCC-Team zusammengeschlossen, weil viele Leute sind in noch guten Aussichten auf einem Platz weit vorne.
Was gibt es denn als Preisgeld eigentlich?
Als Preisgeld, wenn du den Schlüssel findest, gibt es eigentlich 10.000 Dollar Preisgeld. Wenn du bei dem Distributed Net mitmachst, geben davon 8.000 Dollar an eine gemeinnützige Organisation. Welche das ist, darüber wird abgestimmt. Wer die meisten Keys berechnet hat, darf das entscheiden. Ja, und 2.000 Dollar werden aufgeteilt. 1.000 Dollar kriegt der, der zum Rechner den Schlüssel gefunden hat. 1.000 Dollar kriegt das Team. Weil es sind ja eigentlich, man hat ja nicht wirklich was geleistet, im Sinne, außer dass man dabei war und Glück gehabt hat, dass man einfach den richtigen Block zugeteilt bekommen hat.
Gibt es denn jetzt eine Möglichkeit, entweder für andere Leute, auch zu einem Team zusammen zu fließen, oder vielleicht euch noch zu joinen?
Na, es gibt natürlich beide Möglichkeiten. Wir sehen das natürlich gerne, wenn die Leute uns joinen, weil dann unser Team ganz vorne liegt und ihr gehört dann natürlich auch zu dem Team, was ganz vorne liegt, muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Ihr sagt noch mal die Web-Adresse, unter der man mehr Infos kriegt, falls man das jetzt alles noch verschreiben will.
Auf www.ccc.de ist alles ganz prima gelinkt. Nicht weit oben steht immer der Akku.
Gibt es auch eine deutsche Erklärung zufällig?
Ja, es gibt eine Seite, die ich jetzt nicht vorlese, aber das ist gleich der Link mit den Hinweisen auf www.ccc.de. Pluto macht das bei uns und der hat das zusammengefasst, worum es eigentlich geht und wie man daran teilnehmen kann. Im Kern muss man eigentlich nur ein Stück Software auf seinen Rechner runterladen, also einen Client. Den startet man dann und wenn man eine Internetverbindung hat, holt man sich ein paar Keyblöcke und dann werden die gerechnet. Wenn man die ganze Zeit im Internet dran ist mit seinem Computer, dann kann man die auch permanent holen.
Und dann schickt man die einfach wieder zurück und holt sich die nächsten. Das kann man auch mittendrin pausieren. Das pausiert sich von selber, das heißt in dem Moment, wo du aktiv was machst, dann schraubt er sich in der Rechenzahl nach.
Jeden Tag gibt es neue Statistiken und heute sind wir auf Platz 370 nach der Gesamtzahl der errechneten Blöcke und nach der Zahl von Blöcken pro Tag, die wir berechnen, sind wir schon auf Platz 29. Das heißt, wir kommen auf jeden Fall, wenn wir die Keyrate halten, noch...
Wir wollen nach vorne.
Wir werden euch da mal ein bisschen unterstützen.
Über Fritz stehen noch so einige Blöcke.
Wir werden mal rumgehen.
Wir fordern natürlich nicht dazu auf, dass irgendwelche Leute ihre Universitäten hacken und auf einen Rechner kleinen installieren, die für CCCD rechnen müssen. Der entsprechende Systemat und Instrator war nicht amused. Das bringt uns komische Telefonanrufe ein. Wir fordern nicht dazu auf.
Ja, jetzt kommen doch die Daten, Herr Söderbaum.
Das vergrößern Sie jetzt einfach mit dem rechten Mausklick und dann können Sie sich das sehr schön farbig ausbrücken.
Internet für alle heißt der Grundkurs für den Einstieg in die faszinierende Welt des internationalen Datenaustauschs. Ohne besondere Vorkenntnisse gelingt in kürzester Zeit die erste Fahrt auf dem Datenhighway. Dies verdanken die Teilnehmer der praxisnahen Unterweisung von Diplomathematiker Dr. Peter Oetel. Herr Dr. Oetel, wie führen Sie den Computerneulink an das Internet heran?
Nun, Sie haben es ja eben beim Herrn Söderbaum verfolgen können. Am Anfang jeder Internetrecherche steht ein Suchbegriff, den Sie frei wählen können. Herr Söderbaum, was hatten Sie denn da eingegeben? Ich hatte glaube ich dicke Möpse oder so. So sehen Sie, und dann bekommen wir doch eine recht umfangreiche Liste mit Internetseiten, wo wir dann pünktlich werden.
Ja, vielleicht gehen wir erst einmal ganz von den Inhalten weg zu den technischen Details. Herr Dr. Oettel, Stichwort Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit, da hat sich doch eine Menge getan.
Das ist richtig. Das Zauberwort heißt ISTN. Das ist natürlich wie geschaffen für einen ungeduldigen Anwender wie den Herrn Kröger hier. Er bekommt unter der Webadresse www.hausfrauenvon hinten.de sehr großformatige Bilder übertragen und das spart ein schnelles Modem langfristig Zeit und Geld.
Und Geld, ja nun stand beim Internet eigentlich die Idee eines weltweiten persönlichen Datenaustausches an vorderster Stelle. Wie stellt sich das heutzutage da?
Nun dies ist in der Tat eine viel genutzte Chance im Internet. Im Kleinen sehen Sie das ja schon hier beim Herrn Knipphöfer, der sich seit heute Morgen im Datenaustausch mit einem Partner in Tokio befindet. Herr Knipphöfer tauscht Einzelheiten zu seiner Kreditkartennummer gegen Einzelheiten über tabulose thailändische Transvestiten. Ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie die Datenautobahn die Menschen verbindet.
Die Menschen verbindet. Internet für Einsteiger und mit diesem Eindruck von den neuesten Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten zurück ins Funkhaus.
Na Herr Söderbaum, wo hängst du denn jetzt?
Er lässt mich hier nicht rein.
Zeigen sie mal. Ach so, ja hier unten rechts sehen sie, ich bin über 18 und mit allem einverstanden. Dann müssen sie draufklicken.
In dem Chat sind sie alle schon ganz aufgeregt, was ist das, was ist das, wo kriegt man das? Das hat Tim mitgebracht, das ist vom NDR. Da gibt's eine Comedy-Serie, die heißt Neues aus Stenkelfeld. Eine Sendereihe auf NDR 2.
Ich würd mal sagen, von wann ist denn die CD?
Vom letzten Jahr.
Schön getroffen, ne Tim?
Ja, ich bin ja gar nicht der Schuldige, ich hab die nur hierhergetragen. Ich hab irgendwie Martin in die Hand gedrückt und naja, ich hab das gehört und jetzt ist das dabei.
Aber muss man nicht so viel Werbung von NDR machen, ne? Das ist nicht so unser Ziel.
Ich hab irgendwie, wenn es gut ist, naja.
So, lustig soll es auch weitergehen, beziehungsweise ab und zu wird es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen lustig werden, denn wir reden vom Hacker-Jargon, vom Hacker-Slang und da fangen wir doch gleich mit diesem Wort selbst einfach mal an. Was bedeutet denn eigentlich Hack? Wer möchte das übersetzen?
Wer möchte das übersetzen?
Keiner.
Super.
Doch, doch, doch. Ich musste mich gerade mal wieder über das scheiß Timing von Mac OS aufregen.
Das ist echt zum heulen.
Das ist echt unglaublich.
HACK ist das Zauberwort. HACK bedeutet sehr vielstand, aber tatsächlich am Anfang der ganzen Hacker-Entwicklung. Damals, als sich diese Hacker-Geschichte entwickelt hat, Ende der 50er, Anfang der 60er Jahre in Boston am MIT, da gab es eine Gruppe, den Tech Model Railroad Club. Das war eine Eisenbahner-Freunde-Gemeinde, aber die das technisch betrieben haben. Es ging um Modelleisenbahnen. Sie haben in einem großen Raum eine riesige Installation gemacht. Oben gab es die Leute, die sich um die Wagen gekümmert haben und die Bäumchen und dass es schön aussieht. Diese klassischen Eisenbahner-Freunde, die ja auch auf FHB immer ihre Sendungen haben. Unterhalb der Tischplatte gab es die zweite Abteilung dieser Gruppe, die sich einfach Signals and Power nannte. Die für die gesamte Verdrahtung, Verkabelung, Weichenstellung, elektrische Steuerung und so weiter zuständig waren. Aus diesen Leuten haben sich später diese Computer-Hacker entwickelt, nachdem im Nebenraum irgendwie so ein TX-0-Computer angefahren wurde und sie die Gelegenheit hatten, die ganze Nacht vor der Maschine rumzuhängen. Und ihre Tätigkeit, so wie sie da irgendwie dieses System am Laufen gehalten haben und ihre Art und Weise, wie sie sich mit diesen Eisenbahnmodellen und später dann auch mit diesen Computern auseinandergesetzt haben, da war halt eins ihrer Slangwörter hacken, dieses sich reinwerfen, reinsteigern, das ist auch alles nicht so eins zu eins und ohne weiteres übersetzbar. Im Jargon-File, hier so dieser Bibel des Hacker-Slangs, gibt es also nicht nur diese beiden, die wir gerade gehört haben, sondern noch deutlich mehr Begriffe, wie man so Hack ausdrücken kann. Ich meine, was fällt uns ein, wenn man irgendwie irgendwas, wie heißt es hier, original quick job, that produces what is needed, but not well. Also man hat irgendwie das Problem, man muss jetzt irgendeine, irgendwas muss halt laufen, was gerade nicht läuft. Egal, ob das jetzt mit Programmierung zu tun hat oder was auch immer. Bleiben wir vielleicht mal bei Computern irgendwie. Ja, das Programm könnte dieses und jenes.
Ich brauche jetzt mal ein Feature.
Ich brauche halt irgendwas, was irgendwie so und so funktioniert. Dann hack ich mir das rein. Und wenn ich das reingehackt habe, dann ist das Ergebnis auch wiederum ein Hack. Weil ich irgendwie etwas erzeugt habe, was, wie es hier so schön heißt, irgendwie das erzeugt, was es tun soll, wäre noch nicht besonders gut. Aber ein Hack kann auch irgendwie etwas extrem Gutes sein, was also wirklich verdammt gut ist, wo man irgendwie sehr, sehr lange dran gearbeitet hat. Auch das ist dann ein Hack.
Hat das Wort Hack in einer anderen Bedeutung auch was mit dem Reihen Hacken zu tun, also mit der Tätigkeit, mit den Fingern auf die Tastatur zu hauen? Das wird gerne interpretiert, aber irgendwie nicht so recht.
Stetig der Mythos, würde ich sagen.
Passt nicht so ganz, finde ich.
Im Deutschen sicherlich noch ein bisschen mehr, weil für uns dieses Wort sehr lebendig ist. Die deutsche Sprachgebrauchssache ist ja dann auch eine andere, weil wir ja auch mit der englischen Sprache anders umgehen. Für uns ist das ja immer irgendwie erstmal ein Fremdbegriff. Von daher bauen wir das ganz anders in unsere Sprache ein.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz hübsche Geschichte, dass das Wort Hack im Deutschen mit Hack auch wieder funktioniert und hacken und hacken. Ich hab gesehen, dass die Mädchen bei dem CCC oder die Frauen sich dann Hack-zen nennen auch gerne. Und da kann man ja auch eine Menge mit rumspielen.
Mit den Hexen. Ach manchen.
Das meint es aber nicht.
Ich weiß.
Du bist ein gutes Herz.
Nicht möglich.
Ich krieg jetzt drei E-Mails.
Jetzt kriegst du mehr.
Wie viele Frauen sind im TCC?
Das kann ich genauso wenig beantworten wie die Frage, wie viele Männer im TCC sind. Aber es werden prozentual mehr in den letzten Jahren.
Jeden zwei hatten immer mehr.
Als der Kongress zum letzten Mal in Berlin war, vor fünf Jahren, hab ich ja von da berichtet als Reporter. Und da gab es noch eine extra Strecke, die sich damit beschäftigt hat. Speziell über die wichtiger werdende Rolle, beziehungsweise die Rolle war wahrscheinlich schon immer wichtig, aber die zunehmende prozentuale Anzahl von Frauen im Netz, also vor fünf Jahren geredet haben. Und damals war es noch recht wenig. Und es hat sich aber doch ziemlich gesteckt. Aber anderes Thema, das wir sicher auch nochmal als Thema hier haben werden, weiter geht es mit dem Hacker-Slang. Hack haben wir jetzt so ein bisschen versucht zu erklären, um zu sagen, wo es überall herkommt. Hacking ist auch eine Lebenseinstellung. Und da macht sich glaube ich unheimlich viel dran fest, auch in diesem Spieltrieb, der sich dann auch eben in der Sprache wiederfindet. Ich finde es ganz hübsch, dass das von einer Modelleisenbahn irgendwie kommt. Weil ich speziell den PC, der immer offen ist und den man immer rumschraubt, eigentlich sehr gerne mit der Modelleisenbahn vergleiche. Da musste man auch immer zugucken, dass alles funktioniert. Und dann war der Tunnel ein bisschen zu bestellen oder so. Und dann hüpft die aus den Schienen die Eisenbahn, da musst du wieder ran. Wenn die Eisenbahn fertig ist, dann ist es einfach langweilig.
Da muss man immer einfach irgendwie so rumbasteln.
Dann stellt man die in die Ecke.
Also deswegen mochte ich Eisenbahn hier und deswegen musste ich halt einen Mac. Ich fand Autorennbahn besser. Der Mac ist halt einfach irgendwann fertig und dann war es dann so.
Und der ruckelt.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, mit dem fertig sein und das war es dann auch noch dahingestellt. Aber egal, mit welchen Slangbegriffen, was gibt es denn so, was vielleicht auch Leute, die mit dem Internet selber oder mit Computern selber gar nicht so viel zu tun haben, schon gehört haben, weil einiges hat sich ja schon in den allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch eingebürgert.
Na ja, Tim hat gerade bei der Erklärung des Wortes Hack, und zwar hat das Wort nämlich Feature in den Mund genommen, wahrscheinlich ohne es in dem Moment wirklich bewusst zu sagen. Und na ja, ein Feature ist erstmal ein Begriff für eine spezifische Eigenheit eines Programmes oder einer Hardware, die irgendwie nicht auf den ersten Blick offensichtlich ist, sondern etwas, was halt heraussticht als besonders praktische Funktion, im Gegensatz zu einem Bug, was auch heraussticht aber als besonders unpraktische Funktion. Und beide Wörter, sowohl Bug als auch Feature, beginnen sich in den allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch zu schmurren, ganz besonders bei Hacker natürlich. Und wenn man sagt, hey, man kann jetzt irgendwie bei Nachtbussen auch hinten einsteigen, was für ein tolles Feature. Dann macht man eigentlich etwas, was sehr typisch ist für den Hacker-Jargon, nämlich Übergeneralisierung. Wörter, die eigentlich nur eine spezielle, spezifische Bedeutung im Zusammenhang mit Computern haben, im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch zu verwenden und sie zu entleden dafür. Ja, Buck ist dann das nächste. Auch wenn irgendwas einen Fehler hat, dann hat es erst mal einen Buck, einen Käfer.
Du sagst gerade Käfer, Feature ist eigentlich nur eine Eigenschaft.
Ein besonderes, ganz genau übersetzt.
Da müssen wir nachgucken.
Schauen wir doch mal nach, wie das ganz genau ist.
Oder im Film, Featuring, Teilnehmens oder auch Anwesend.
Schauen wir nochmal, was das tolle Buch dazu sagt.
Ja, wir haben das ja mal extra.
Hier gibt es natürlich wieder mal mehrere Sachen. Ihr dürft erstmal weiter reden, ich schau mal kurz hier.
Tim, guckt mal und bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir ein, dass gerade in den realsprachlichen Zusammenhängen, dass dann öfter, wo ist Tim, der ist noch nicht gebootet, sprich der Licht, der liegt noch im Bett, ne? Zum Beispiel und ich erinnere mich an den Tag, wo Tim also tatsächlich aufwachte und Pirekrat, neknekneknek, machte nach dem Aufwachen und da seine Ramme hochzielte. Auch da wieder deute ich die Verbindung, dass das tatsächlich zu einer Lebenseinstellung gehört, weil das fällt einem sonst nicht ein direkt, als erstes nach dem Aufwachen. Steini, du kannst ja vielleicht, während Tim noch sucht, was Feature genau bedeutet, kannst du mal erklären, wo so Bug-Käfer herkommt. Warum ist eine Fehlfunktion oder ein Anti-Feature sozusagen ein Bug? Warum ist das ein Käfer?
Ich glaube, das weiß Andreas besser. Der wirkliche Ursprung davon ist nicht belegt. Es gibt aber aus einem der ersten Computer, der mit Release funktionierte, einen Eintrag in einem Tagebuch, wo tatsächlich ein Käfer in der Seite klebte und drunter stand, so etwas wie First Incident of a Real Bug, also das erste Auftreten eines tatsächlichen Bugs. Die Ursprünge dieses Begriffes liegen in der Dunkelheit vergraben, aber es ist ein sehr interessanter Prozess zu beobachten. Und zwar muss man ja verschiedene Formen der Sprache unterscheiden. Da gibt es einmal das, was man als TechSpeak bezeichnen kann, also einfach Fachbegriffe für bestimmte Umstände. Und dann gibt es etwas, was man eher Jargon nennen könnte, also Wörter, die von Leuten verwendet werden, erstmal um sich ein bisschen Humor da reinzubringen, um sich auch abzugrenzen, um mit wenigen Worten viel auszudrücken. Also es ist auch immer sehr assoziationsreich. Und gerade bei Buck ist es so, dass das ein Wort ist, das angefangen hat als so Jargon, der informell gebraucht wurde und das dann aber später in den offiziellen TechSpeak geschafft hat. Also ein Buck ist mittlerweile ein hochoffizieller Begriff für einen Softwarefehler und man kann auch bei den stinksteifesten Firmen einen Buck-Report abgeben mittlerweile. Genau. Und ein Debugger ist ein Programm, der halt diesen Käfer wieder entfernt.
Na, der einen suchen lässt mit einem Debugger, kann man den suchen und entfernen, das muss man aber schon von Hand machen. Dann gibt es noch die Bugs-Fixes, also die, letzten Endes die Lösungen, um diesen Buck zu entfernen. Und das sind jetzt wirklich feststehende Begriffe.
Das mit dem Käfer ist auch in dem wunderschönen Film Brasilia so wunderbar drin. Da fällt auch ein Käfer oben von der Decke, nachdem der Bürokrat ihn gejagt hat, irgendwie direkt in die Typow-Reiter-Maschine, die dann halt nicht buttelt, sondern tattelt. Dann kommt diese ganze Battle-Tattel-Konfusion und alles. Das ist irgendwie total discordisch. Feature, naja, die beste Beschreibung finde ich prominent part. Also ein Teil, der sozusagen in gewisser Hinsicht prominent ist, der heraussticht. Das wird hier sowohl für Gesichtselemente, als auch eben für Artikel in einer Zeitung, die eine besondere Bedeutung haben, machen. Zum Beispiel, es gibt diesen schönen Satz, it's not a bug, it's a feature. Man ruft irgendwie bei Nokia an, naja, aber ihr Telefon tut ja das und das nicht. Und dann ist halt so die Antwort, ja, aber da können sie ja dann dieses und jenes tun. Microsoft ist da auch immer wunderbar, nicht? Die haben also auch überall Features, die wir halt eigentlich eher Bugs nennen sollten.
Wir werden natürlich auch auf die ganzen Abkürzungen zu sprechen kommen. Es gibt ja dieses, was bestimmt jeder schon mal erlebt hat, der einen Bekannten oder eine Bekannte, die das Internet noch nie gesehen hat, zum Beispiel vor dem Chat setzt und der die Dinge verstehen kein Wort, weil er laute Abkürzungen benutzt werden, die ja nicht unbedingt nur um kryptisch zu sein erfunden wurden, sondern auch durchaus in einer Zeit wahrscheinlich entstanden sind als die Datenübertragung noch sehr viel langsamer war, als es vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt so angebracht war, Sachen auszuformulieren. Man will es einfach nicht eintippen.
Aus Bedürfnissen HHOS. Das ist ein interessantes Stichwort, weil Computerleute reden halt viel über Technik, über Funktionen und damit verbunden natürlich auch mit Effizienz. Und das schlägt sich in ihre Sprachgewohnheiten wieder mit rein, dass sie auch ihre Sprache auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise modellieren, Steuern vollständig funktional bedienen wollen, eine maximaleffiziente Kommunikation erzeugen wollen, die natürlich jetzt für Normalbürger irgendwie alles andere als effizient ist, weil sie verstehen halt einfach nur Bahnhof. Aber innerhalb der Computerszene selber funktioniert das wunderbar. Man kann da einfach mit sehr, sehr wenigen Worten und Buchstaben und Zahlen und manchmal einfach nur nicht sagen von irgendetwas, sehr, sehr viel ausdrücken. Man will den Kanal immer einfach zur Verfügung hat, voll ausreißen.
Genau, Bandbreiten.
Heute geht es aber dann irgendwie bei Newbies, da sind wir ja schon wieder bei so einem Wort, bei Neu-Eingestiegenen, das sind Newbies, da braucht man nicht viel zu erklären. Das kommt wahrscheinlich aus allen möglichen anderen Bereichen, wahrscheinlich aus dem Golfclub.
Das kann schon immer so sein. Das können wir gleich noch mal irgendwie recherchieren.
Aber jedenfalls Leute, die neu dazukommen, wo es vielleicht nicht mehr so unbedingt das Thema ist, dass man sich technisch effizient ausdrücken will oder so, sondern man bekommt es doch durchaus aus so einem Hit-Miss-Status, oder? Wer die meisten Abkürzungen kennt. Also ich stell jetzt so fest im Fritz-Chat öfter mal.
Also Chat ist eine eigene Welt. Da sollte man vielleicht auch nachher noch mal irgendwie gezielter drauf gehen.
Also hier kommen gerade ein paar Worte zum Beispiel auf dem Bildschirm, wie zum Beispiel Leimer. Kann man vielleicht auch noch mal was zu sagen.
Aber es gibt ja auch irgendwie so deutsche Abkürzungen wie Dau zum Beispiel, das fällt mir gehört ein. Ja, das ist übrigens etwas, was halt in offiziellen Jargon-Fallen noch nicht geschafft hat. Das ist irgendwie so ein, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange es den schon gibt. Ja, echt Dau. Dau ist das einzige, was es überhaupt geschafft hat. Dürmster? Dau ist tatsächlich drin. Das ist einer der wenigen deutschen Begriffe.
In welches Buch guckt ihr dann immer?
Wir gucken in ein Buch, dazu muss man weiter ausholen. Dieses Buch heißt The New Hacker's Dictionary, Third Edition. Und hat angefangen als Zusammenstellung von Begriffen aus diesem Tech Model Railroad Club in den 50ern und war halt ein File, das von Platte zu Platte wanderte. Und jeder hatte mal ein bisschen was dran editiert und hinzugeschrieben und sogar die gängigen Begriffe und Phänomene reingeschrieben. Und die Datei hieß jargon.txt. Genau, und deswegen heißt diese Datei das Jargon File. Und derzeit wird das Jargon File von Eric Raymond editiert und aktuell gehalten. Das ist der Mensch, der aus den Halloweenpapers bekannt ist und dem Kathedralen und Basar-Paper. Und mittlerweile einer der prominentesten Open-Source-Propagandisten ist. Und das gibt es halt auch in gedruckter Form, was ganz praktisch ist, wenn man es dann auch in der Badewanne oder im Zug lesen kann.
Sag doch mal den Verlag kurz, für alle, die jetzt gleich fragen werden.
Der Verlag ist The MIT Press, die passend. Massachusetts Institute of Technology, Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Was die alles so machen, ne?
Also da, wo es herkommt. Also dieser Tech Model Railroad Club war halt am MIT. Und das Jargon-File gibt es natürlich auch im Netz, als Postgrip, halala, HTML, alles. Unter www.toxedo.org/jargon.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich die offizielle Adresse.
Das ist dann alles so.
Das schicken wir dann auch immer gerne in unseren Feedback nachträglich raus.
Ihr fragt jemand, ob in diesem Jargon-File steht, was Pish bedeutet. Die gehört euch auch nicht gehört.
Frag doch mal den Bot.
Der Bot funktioniert noch nicht so richtig irgendwie.
Der Martin hat irgendwie so einen Bot programmiert für den Chat, irgendwie im WBW-Chat, der irgendwie solche Fragen direkt beantwortet. Aber ich glaube, der hat noch so ein bisschen Kommunikationsprobleme. Nee, Pish ist nicht drin.
Pish, nee, ich guck auch gerade mal an Jargonfile hier auf der Platte.
Aber Pish, muss er schon selber erklären, kennen wir auch nicht. Bei Jargonfile, ich mein, das ist ein wirklich außergewöhnliches Buch. Das ist nicht nur so ein Verzeichnis von Worten, sondern er geht auch gerade in den ersten Kapitel sehr ausführlich auf die Gründe und die Hintergründe ein, warum eigentlich diese Szene so spricht. Er zeichnet einfach mehrere Sachen relativ gut raus. Zum Beispiel der Humor, den die Hacker so treibt. Dieser Spaß an Zahlen, der sich nicht nur in solchen Filmen wie 23 und so weiter widerspiegelt, sondern einfach dieses Rechnen, das Mathematische, das Logische, das findet eben dann auch seine Wiederkehr in den Humor der Hacker. So und überhaupt ist die ganze Sprache davon geprägt von Humor. Es ist ein grundlegenden, wirklich eine sehr humorvolle Jargon-Sammlung.
Gibt es irgendwas, gibt es Hacker-Witze? Also Witze, oder ja, Witze, die nur Leute verstehen, die sich schwer mit Computern auseinandersetzen?
Ja, sodass die Kräne endlos schleifeln in 10 Minuten.
Den kannte ich noch nicht.
War der schweinisch oder?
Andererseits. Ja, aber vielleicht um nochmal ein Beispiel zu bringen, was man vielleicht auch erklären kann, ohne Leichenfletterei zu betreiben. Ein typischer Spruch für, wenn man mal wieder gerade nicht klicken kann, ist Internet ist kaputt. Warum der so witzig ist, ist natürlich relativ leicht zu erklären, weil das Internet echt verdammt groß ist. Und wenn man sagt, Internet ist kaputt, dann drückt man damit aus, dass man einfach überhaupt gar keine Ahnung hat, was vor sich geht. Und wenn man aber doch Ahnung hat, was vor sich geht und dann trotzdem diesen Satz verwendet, drückt das aus, dass man weiß, dass es sehr komplexes Problem ist, dass man aber keine Idee hat, was das Problem ist. Oder vielleicht weiß man es auch und geht davon aus, dass der andere schon weiß, was los ist.
Ich hab noch ein anderes Beispiel, ich hab das aus persönlicher Erfahrung kommt, das hat aber bestimmt auch schon jeder von euch mal gehört. Von Leuten, die großes Interesse haben, dass man ihnen das mal zeigt, die stellen sich dann vor den Rechner und sagen, mach mal Internet. Was ich auch immer sehr hübsch finde. Und seitdem hab ich das auch so als Standard gesprochen.
Ich will auch ein Internet.
Ich ruf mir auch so ein Internet.
Genau, haben sie hier auch ein Internet.
Wir lachen erstmal noch ein bisschen. Ihr hört Chaosradio, den monatlichen Computable Moon bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Sonja im Mikrofon. Und das Thema ist Hacker-Slang, Hacker-Jargon. Wir haben schon über das Jargon-File geredet und wo es herkommt, dass man es in Buchform und natürlich in elektronischer Form bekommen kann. Und vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal so ein paar Wörter in den Raum stellen und erklären oder auch Abkürzungen mal entschlüsseln und wir werden natürlich auch noch Gelegenheit haben hier anzurufen und uns ist wie immer keine Frage zu doof. Wenn ihr euch jetzt zum Beispiel seit Jahren damit rumschlägt, was bedeutet eigentlich IMHO? Zum Beispiel, was ja nicht so einfach ist, weil zumindest ein Wort drin vorkommt, was nicht so ein gebräuchliches englisches Wort ist.
Das ist richtig.
IMHO in my humble opinion?
In meiner jederwärtigen, unterwürfigen, nicht weiter relevanten und niemand interessierenden Meinung. Da kann man gleich ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Diese neue Kommunikation, die durch Internet und andere Netze ermöglicht wurde, durch e-Mail und vor allem im Newsnet, also in den Newsgroups, warf ein ganz neues Problem auf, weil man kommunizierte ernsthaft miteinander, aber es schielten sehr viele Dinge, die man so im Real-Life hat. RL ist auch eine interessante Abkürzung. Es fällt die optische Kontrolle weg. Man kann verschmitzt gucken und was Böses sagen, und dann weiß jeder, das war nicht so gemeint. Wenn ich aber verschmitzt gucke und eine böse Mail schreibe, dann kommt nur die böse Mail an und die Leute regen sich sofort auf, woraufhin ein Flame War ausbricht. Um einen Flame War zu entgehen, gibt es bestimmte Akronyme, die generelle Formulierung, die man keine Lust hat, immer wieder zu schreiben, um deutlicher auszudrücken, wie man es gerade gemeint hat. Wenn ich imho an Anfang eine Satz stelle, dann drücke ich damit deutlich aus, ich sage jetzt mal was, aber ich bin selber nicht so sicher, das muss nicht das letzte aller Worte sein, oder ich will das auch keinem aufdrücken.
Ich wollte das nur kurz mal anmerken.
Ein bisschen Understatement.
Oder auch, Spitze Klammer G, Spitze Klammer Z, heißt Grin, dann drückt man aus, dass wenn man das sagt, dass man dann grint.
Das gibt es auch mit Sternchen.
Dann gibt es noch Sternchen SICK, S-I-C Sternchen.
Weiß jemand, was das genau war?
SICK heißt, das ist allerdings was, was mit Netz glaube ich erstmal nicht so viel zu tun haben. SICK bedeutet, ich weiß nicht mehr wofür es wirklich steht, aber es bedeutet, das ist tatsächlich so.
Das ist eine Geschichte aus der lateinischen Abkürzung.
Ja, irgendwie, ich wusste es, man hat es vergessen.
Nein, das ist mit K.
Mit G heißt es wirklich, wenn man eine unglaubliche Geschichte erzählt oder jemand zitiert und dann SICK dahinter schreibt, dann bedeutet es einfach, das hat er tatsächlich so gesagt.
Wir können ja mal das Telefon aufreißen und fragen, ob jemand genau weiß, was das ist.
Vielleicht kann uns jemand erklären, wo SICK herkommt. S-I-C, das können bestimmt auch einige Leute, die mit Netz oder Computern gar nichts zu tun haben. RTFM wurde gerade noch kurz erwähnt. Wenn ihr irgendwann mal in einer Newsgroup teilnehmt und als Antwort-Mail nur RTFM bekommt, dann ist der Tipp, wie immer, erst lesen und dann schreiben, dann heißt es Read the fucking Manual.
Das hat sich natürlich weggenommen, ne?
Wieso?
Na ja, eigentlich wenn jemand was Doofes fragt, dann sagt man halt RTFM. Und wenn er dann fragt, was heißt RTFM, dann sagt man, das heißt Read the Manual first. Woraufhin er dann meistens sehr glücklich ist, aber erst 10 Minuten später merkt, dass die Abkürzung nicht passen kann.
Und wenn er dann immer noch nachfragt, dann betont man halt Read the fucking Manual.
Mal gucken. Was heißt denn SICK?
Wir gucken mal. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hier ist Chaos Radio.
Ups, jetzt aber.
Ja, hallo, hier ist Thomas.
Hallo Thomas. Weißt du, wofür SICK steht?
SICK ist gar kein Akronym oder eine Abkürzung.
Es ist einfach lateinisch und heißt, so viel ich weiß, so.
Ah, das hätte ich eigentlich wissen müssen, mit einem kleinen Latinum im Rücken. Naja, das hab ich auch geschenkt gekriegt.
Oder heißt SICK nicht, so ist das oder so was?
Ja, das heißt einfach nur so. Die Römer haben ja manchmal das EST gar nicht gesagt, sondern einfach nur bei solchen Sätzen das EST weggelassen. Das ist einfach nur so hingestellt. Das heißt dann so bla. Das ist wirklich so eine Übersetzung.
Gut, also keine Abkürzung, sondern tatsächlich einfach nur ein lantanisches Wort.
Ist doch schön, dass wir alle Abi haben, oder?
Ja, und so lang gibt es das Internet auch schon.
Seit den Römern.
Seit dem römischen Reich. Danke dir.
Nicht zu danken.
So, haben wir SICK geklärt, HALTEX zumindest. Da keine massenhaften Protestanrufe gekommen, denke ich, dass das dann auch stimmt. Mann, das ist peinlich. Was gibt es denn noch so an Beschimpfungen? Wir haben ja vorhin von Flame Wars geredet, auch in Newsgroups entstanden, als sie noch überschaubar waren. Flame Wars entstehen einfach leicht dann, wenn unter Umständen auch durch ein Missverständnis, wenn jemand, also Newsgroup für alle nochmal, ist eine Art schwarzes Brett, und ich schreibe da was hin, und das versteht jemand falsch und fühlt sich angepisst und antwortet ein bisschen heftiger als ich erwartet hätte.
Da gibt es Streit ohne Ende.
Da gibt es Streit und alles mischt sich ein, und plötzlich hat man, jeder kann da was zu sein.
Genau, also eine Flame ist einfach eine böse Antwort auf etwas, was man irgendwie schon böse aufgefasst hat, warum auch immer, ob richtig oder nicht, und wenn dann halt eine Flame auf die andere kommt, dann haben wir dann irgendwann den Flame War, und dann sind Newsgroups meistens nicht mehr zu genießen oder die Mailing-Bitte.
Interessant ist das, wenn die Leute dann mal zusammenkommen, dann ist dieser Grund für den Flame War innerhalb von Minuten meistens geklärt. Weil durch die Gestik, Mimik und so weiter man sehr schnell begreiflich machen kann, wo eigentlich das Problem hängt, und in Schriftsprache geht das halt mitunter nicht so gut. Und dafür gibt es dann auch, bürgert sich immer mehr ein, dass man einen Tag von einem Absatz macht, einen HTML-Tag, der dann aber einen echtsprachlichen Inhalt hat. Man macht zum Beispiel die Spitzeklammer auf, sagt Ironie on, Spitzeklammer zu, dann kommt ein Absatz, und dann macht man eine eckige Klammer auf, Schrägstrich Ironie, eckige Klammer oder off. Und was dazwischen steht, das war dann ironisch gemeint. Weil man das halt mit der Stimmlage nicht hinbekommt. Ich würde übrigens vorhersagen wollen, dass sich das innerhalb der nächsten Monate oder vielleicht ein, zwei Jahre garantiert auch bei anderen schreibenden Menschen ansatzweise durchsetzen wird. Man erkennt ja zum Beispiel viele Geschichten im Journalismus oder in Lifestyle-Magazinen zum Beispiel, dass so Sachen aus dem Netz benutzt werden.
Smilies zum Beispiel.
Smilies zum Beispiel, also weiß ich nicht.
Es kommt gleich mal zu.
Ad zum Beispiel, ganz beliebt. Was glaube ich kommt, ist der Unterstrich definitiv.
Ja, der hat eine große Zukunft denke ich auch.
Und ich glaube ganz bestimmt werden diese HTML-Tags kommen für bestimmte Sachen. Ich meine, wir sind ja ständig auf der Suche nach Neuigkeiten in Schriftform und wie können wir unseren Text anders gestalten oder speziell in bestimmten Zahlschriften. Vielleicht sollten wir auf den Unterstrich nochmal eingehen. Ein Unterstrich macht man ja auch gerne dann, wenn man ein Wort ganz besonders meint. Dann kommt ein Unterstrich vorne weg, dann kommt das Wort, dann kommt ein Unterstrich dahinter.
Oder ein Stern.
Denn damals gab es noch nicht Microsoft Outlook, was jede Mail doppelt so groß macht, weil keiner daran denkt, den HTML-Scheiß unten anzuschalten. Ich sage sowas wirklich immer aus Erfahrung. Also die ganzen Mails, die kommen, das nimmt wirklich zu, dass die immer einmal im normalen Text kommen. Und da stehen sie unten nochmal als HTML-Datei.
Das nennt sich dann Rich Media.
Vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal wirklich, gerade so in der Szene gilt es als absolut peinlich, seine Mails in HTML zu verschicken.
Wirklich, das ist das letzte, das ist schlimm.
Blöde ist nur, man kann es ja vielen Leuten wirklich nicht übel nehmen.
Das ist einfach on by default.
Das Problem ist, dass es angeschaltet ist. Ich finde, dass Microsoft sowieso eine Firma ist, die ganz spezialisiert darin ist, sämtliche bekloppten Funktionen einfach by default an, also default kann man vielleicht auch nochmal erklären, ob sie an sind. Ich muss stundenlang suchen, bis ich weiß, wo ich den Mist abschalte. Das geht mir in Word zum Beispiel so, dass ich schicke einen Brief und schreibe eine URL und die ist plötzlich unterstrichen und als Link und in einem anderen Schrifttyp. Manchmal muss ich.
Sie zwingen dich dazu.
Sie zwingen mich dazu, mit Geld.
Erklär uns doch mal, was default heißt.
Default ist die Grund, also die default ist Grundeinstellung. Ich weiß aber nicht, was default ganz wörtlich übersetzt.
Die Vorgabe, dass was da ist, wenn nichts anderes da ist.
Bevor man das ändert, ist das dann anders.
Was heißt das wörtlich übersetzt?
Heißt das Vorgabe?
Ich weiß nicht, wörtlich übersetzt. Ich finde nicht, dass man Englisch wirklich übersetzen kann.
Das sollte man auch nicht tun.
Die Leute versuchen immer, meinen Namen zu übersetzen. Aber ich kann ja noch mal das schlaue Oxford Buch fragen. Was mir gerade noch auffällt, wo wir gerade so über Satzzeichen reden und so. Auch das ist etwas, was natürlich Computerleute sehr genau nehmen, denn wenn sie Programmtext schreiben, zählt nun mal jedes Simikolon an der richtigen Stelle. Und ist es halt an der falschen, dann ist es ein Bug. Und es gibt so Konventionen in der deutschen Grammatik, wenn man jetzt mal dem Duden folgt, wie man einen Satz zu schreiben hat, die widersprechen so ein bisschen dem Lebensgefühl und dem Selbstverständnis, wie Computerleute mit Text umgehen. Das ist zum Beispiel zu bemerken bei dem Anführungsstrich. Wenn man einen Teil eines Satzes in Anführungsstriche setzt und dieser Teil ist dann auch noch am Ende eines Satzes, dann kommt ja am Satzenden normalerweise ein Punkt und die deutsche Schreibung sagt, wenn der Anführungsstrich am Schluss ist, dann wird der Anführungsstrich hinter den Punkt gesetzt. Das ist natürlich für Computerleute überhaupt nicht zu akzeptieren, weil der Punkt ist halt der End-of-Sentence-Terminator, der Delimiter, das Zeichen, was einfach klar macht, hier ist der Satz zu Ende. Und der Anführungsstrich ist sozusagen der Delimiter für Special Text. Man kann nur nicht den Punkt irgendwie reinsetzen und danach nochmal den Special Delimiter, das ist einfach ein Sündungsfehler. Da fehlt ein Punkt. Ja genau, da fehlt ein Punkt. Das ist halt ein Fehler. Und deswegen wird das nicht so benutzt. Also in Computerhandbüchern, die ja dann meistens auch von Tech-Leuten geschrieben sind, da merkt man eben, dass es anders benutzt wird. Es geht auch so weit, dass Begriffe, die klein geschrieben werden, dann auch am Satz Anfang klein geschrieben werden. Weil wenn man sie groß schreibt, ist es ja was anderes und dann funktioniert es ja nicht mehr.
Ist ja überhaupt der Trend zu Kleinschreibungen gerade.
Ich hab den Trend gerade zurück. Seitdem ich E-Mails schreibe, schreibe ich alles klein. Also nur in E-Mails, nicht in anderen Briefen. Aber ich glaube, ich gewöhne mir das wieder ab.
Kommt es nicht klar?
Doch, ich komme wunderbar klar.
Also es ist schon Bestandteil der Sprache und man sollte das auch machen. Es besteht ja kein Grund, die Sprache nicht zu ändern, wenn sie sinnvoll ist. Manche Sachen groß zu schreiben, ist halt schon sinnvoll. Aber manchmal muss man sie halt klein schreiben, dann sollte man sie klein schreiben.
Das ist schön gesagt.
Das war dann auch unser Beitrag zur Rechtschreibreform. Gibt es irgendwas, ihr, die euch mit dieser anderen Art oder Form von deutscher und englischer Sprache beschäftigt, wenn ihr z.B. Stichwort Rechtschreibreform, wird das irgendwas, wo ihr gesagt hättet, das würde ich sofort ändern, das würde ich sofort in die offizielle Grammatik einfließen lassen, weil das unheimlich Sinn macht.
Von der neuen Rechtschreibreform. Also was mich an der neuen Rechtschreibreform ärgert, ist, dass die Regeln nicht, sind ein Tick weniger geworden, aber sind neu hinzugekommen. Was für ein Blödsinn. Das mit dem SZ, jetzt gibt es wieder besondere Fälle, wo man dann doch Doppel-S statt SZ schreibt. Das macht aber durchaus Sinn.
Also wir hätten es ganz einfach abschaffen können.
Die Schweizer haben es jetzt auch hinbekommen, irgendwie dieses SZ abzuschaffen.
Was heißt abschaffen?
Es ist nicht wirklich viel logischer geworden.
Nein, ich finde man soll, also Rechtschreibreform, ich finde, wo ein SZ steht, darf auch ein SS stehen. Doppel S ist da völlig okay, wo ein SS steht. Na also wenn wir darüber reden, da gibt es durchaus Leute, die sagen, da stirbt ein Buchstabe, ein ganzer Buchstabe, denen das einfach auch... Ja, das ist aber ganz tragisch.
Und das SZ...
Nein, das ist nicht ganz, das wollte ich nicht so einfach vom Tisch wischen.
Das SZ spielt ja eine Rolle, wie lange man eine Silbe spricht, ob man sie ist oder ist, so ausspricht. Wobei, da ist halt die Sprache, so wie sie bisher definiert war, eben auch nicht stimmig, dass man irgendwie, wo es kurz gesprochen wurde, trotzdem irgendwie ein SZ war, mal ist es lang, mal nicht. Und jetzt ist es in der neuen Rechtschreibung zumindest an vielen Stellen so korrigiert worden.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass eine ganze Tradition einer Umgangssprache verloren geht, eines Dialektes, sondern herje.
Wir haben ja mit dem Deutschen auch echt das Glück, dass wir eine sehr lebendige Sprache haben, die sich noch erweitert, wo Fremdwörter aufgenommen werden. Also gerade diese Computergeschichte ist ein schönes Beispiel. Die Amis haben halt das Problem, wenn man da sagt, wer Stack sagt, dann heißt das halt auch Stapel und man weiß nicht, dass man von einem Stack redet, wenn man Stack sagt. Und deshalb verstehe ich auch nicht Leute, die zum Stack Kellerspeicher sagen.
Oder Stapelspeicher gibt es ja auch.
Eigentlich war natürlich meine Frage von den Rechtschreibreformen gar nicht so auf die wirkliche Rechtschreibreform bezogen, sondern gibt es irgendwas, wo ihr im täglichen E-Mail schreibt, im Posten, in Newsgroups, in HTML schreibt? Gibt es da irgendwas, was ihr vermisst, wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel einen Brief ans Finanzamt schreiben müsst? Oder wo ihr sagt, ich wünschte, ich könnte jetzt die Smiley-Dannchen schicken.
Aber Schlossgeld sind zum Beispiel nicht so unser Ding.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, das ist für mich eine Nullinformation.
Ja, okay, aber es gibt ja echt über... Das könnte man mit einem Zeichen sagen. Genau. Es gibt ja inzwischen auch, da sind wir denn bei deutschen Abkürzungen. Also MFG zum Beispiel hat sich durchaus durchgesetzt. Wobei ich MFG anstelle von mit freundlichen Grüßen schon immer irgendwie ein bisschen nackt, was ich finde. Ja, das kann man dann auch echt einfach weglassen.
Das Donnerhacke ist da echt der, der das auf die Spitze treibt. Der hat schon Postings gepostet, wo er 5-6 Zeilen gequotet hat und dann ein einziges ASCII-Zeichen drunter. Wenn man das mal nachgeguckt hat, das war das ASCII-Zeichen, das auch noch die Bedeutung ACK hat, für acknowledge. Oder auch, das ist richtig, was du gesagt hast. Und dieses ACK, also ausgeschrieben als ACK, setzt sich auch so langsam durch, um zu sagen, ich finde, du hast Recht.
Das ist das einzige Zeichen dann dafür?
Das einzige Zeichen ist, ich hab die Tabelle nicht im Kopf. Eins von 0 bis 32, diese ganzen Kontrollcharacters, die lachenden Männchen und so was. Also ein Kontrollzeichen wird aber geschrieben haben, ne? Kontroll irgendwas. Eine von den ersten ist das. Hat jemand eine ASCII-Tabelle an den Griff?
Hab ich eine ASCII-Tabelle auf meinem Computer? Wir gucken mal. Gleich gibt's ein Fritz-Korz-Info, da gucken wir weiter. Schon wieder?
So schnell, so geht die Zeitstein.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
23 über 30.
Personal, die Berliner SPD hat Umweltsenatorin Strida zum neuen Landesvorsitzenden gewählt. Er rief die Partei zur Geschlossenheit auf, um die Große Koalition abzulösen. Strida war vom SPD-Spitzenkandidaten Mompo vorgeschlagen worden. Beide wollen nach der Abgeordnetenhaushalm im Oktober einen rot-grünen Senat bilden. Mahnung, in Berlin-Pankow haben am Abend rund 1000 Menschen mit einer Lichterkette der Opfer des Nationalsozialismus gedacht. Zulang protestierten sie gegen das Vorhaben der Republikaner, ihre Bundesgeschäftsstelle in einer ehemaligen jüdischen Villa einzurichten.
Abstimmung, das Amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen US-Präsident Clinton geht weiter. Der US-Senat beschloss die Vernehmung von Zeugen.
Die republikanische Mehrheit lud unter anderem Monika Lewinsky zu einer Befragung vor. Unfall. Vor der Nordseeinsel Norderney sind zwei Tornado-Flugzeuge der Bundeswehr zusammengestoßen und ins Meer gestürzt. Zwei Besatzungsmitglieder wurden verletzt, geborgen.
Zwei Piloten werden noch vermisst.
Vorfall. In Jemen sind erneut mehrere Deutsche verschleppt worden. Es handelt sich offenbar um eine Entwicklungshelferin und ihre Familie. Das Auswärtige Amt erklärte, man habe noch keinen Kontakt mit den Helführern. In die Sonne ist vor uns zeitweise Schneefreibe, Temperaturen zwischen 0 und minus 2 Grad, dann taget erneut Schnee und Werte zwischen 1 und 4 Grad. Weiterhin keine aktuellen Meldungen und wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Ein Fritz Kurzin von Matthias Klarkoff.
Entspannung?
WAMULE in Berlin.
Absoluter Beginner, live in Berlin, Mittwoch, 10. Februar im SO36.
Wir hören Chaosradio, Computer Blumen bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, außer wenn es ausnahmsweise mal einen anderen Tag. Der Mittwoch bleibt eigentlich häufig, aber...
Nächstes Mal klappt das leider schon wieder nicht. Bitte?
Ist aber auch Mittwoch.
Achso, ja es ist ja Mittwoch, aber es ist leider nicht der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Die nächste Sendung ist am 3. März.
Ich bin wie immer der letzte, der von da fährt.
Ach ich komm, dann haben wir extra...
Ich prüfe mich an, ich komm vorbei. Ach dann ist schon okay. So, damit ihr nicht einrostet da zuhause, seid ihr jetzt ein bisschen gefragt. Wir wollen, dass ihr hier anruft. Wir wollen von euch Fragen haben, wenn ihr Internetbenutzer seid oder Benutzerinnen. Fragt uns, welche Abkürzungen ihr nicht kennt. Fragt uns, welche Wörter euch überhaupt nicht sagen. Fragt uns, wie man ein bestimmtes Wort aussprechen muss. Denn das ist ja das Erstaunliche, sind wir überhaupt nicht erstaunlich. Man liest ja doch meistens und schreibt im Netz. Und wenn man dann mit englischen Wörtern um sich schmeißt, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass man auch weiß, wie sie ausgesprochen werden, falls man sich mal darüber unterhalten will. Also, ihr könnt uns anrufen und nach der Bedeutung von bestimmten Wörtern oder Abkürzungen fragen. Und wir werden da natürlich dann im Speziellen ganz sicher auch nochmal auf das spezielle Thema Chats zu sprechen kommen, IOC oder Webchats oder was auch immer, wie sie alle heißen, die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, um miteinander zu reden, in Anführungsstrichen. Denn da werden am meisten Abkürzungen benutzt, unter anderem. Deswegen wollen wir damit eine Menge Zeit sparen.
Ja, wir wollen uns aber nicht über Chat unterhalten, sondern darüber, wie man sich im Chat unterhält.
Genau, also da müssen wir schon einen Unterschied machen. Ihr könnt hier anrufen, ihr kennt wahrscheinlich die Normal.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 03314Potsdam 7097 110.
Chaosradio zum Thema Hacker-Slang, Hacker-Jargon, Abkürzungen und spezielles Sprachliches im Internet. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo.
Ich bin Stefan.
Hallo Stefan.
Ja, ich bin jetzt mal live drauf. Ich hab's nicht geglaubt. Ich hab's angerufen und bin live da.
Da freuen wir uns auch.
Abkürzung, ja Abkürzung kenne ich sehr gut. Ich studiere gerade an einer Universität hier.
Das ist praktisch.
Wo sonst solltest du auch studieren?
Stefan, hast du eine bestimmte Frage zu einer bestimmten Abkürzung?
Eigentlich nicht, nur ich wollte dich mal aufregen darüber, wie viele tolle Abkürzungen es gibt. Ja, es wird eigentlich sich nur noch darüber unterhalten, über Abkürzungen.
Das nervt dich?
Ja, es nervt mich.
Was ist denn deine Lieblingsabkürzung und was ist die meistgehasste Abkürzung?
Also, ich meine, wir machen sehr viel über ISDN zum Beispiel. Und es kann einfach nicht sein, dass man sich nur noch über Abkürzungen unterhält. Das wird teilweise nur noch zu getan.
Aber dabei ist doch der S0-Bus vom Integrated Services Digital Network eine wirklich interessante Sache.
Ja, natürlich.
Also du meinst, man sollte nicht ISDN sagen, sondern man sollte...
Nein, sicherlich nicht.
Aber man kann es ja nun wirklich übertreiben.
Kennst du denn viele Leute, die tatsächlich auch, also nicht nur in E-Mail oder wenn sie sich technisch unterhalten, sondern tatsächlich in ihrer ganz normalen Sprache, also wenn sie sich miteinander unterhalten, damit mit unglaublich vielen Abkürzungen rumwerfen. Ich meine, wir tun es hier klar, aber es ist ja auch eine Sendung, die sich mit Technik auseinandersetzt.
Ja, also bei uns ist es auch so, dass wir uns ein bisschen mit Abkürzungen unterhalten.
Was studierst du denn eigentlich?
Nachricht und Technik.
Da hat man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mit Abkürzungen zu tun.
Ja, na sicher.
Wenn es dich stört, hast du vielleicht das falsche studiert.
Nein, glaube ich nicht. Aber darf man das abgesehen. Es stört mich einfach ein bisschen, weil man schließt doch eine gewisse Menge an Leuten aus, die man einfach, man sagt einfach irgendwelche Abkürzungen und die Leute, die es nicht verstehen, die sind einfach draußen aus dem Kreis.
Okay, Stefan, danke erstmal.
Weniger Abkürzungen also. Stefan mag das nicht.
Er hat ja Recht. Er hat Recht und natürlich ist die Sprache auch dazu gedacht, bestimmte Leute auszuschließen, weil nur dadurch kann man eben bestimmte andere Leute, an denen er ihm gelegen ist, einschließen.
Die Frage ist halt, wenn ich mich über Nachrichtentechnik unterhalte, dann schließe ich alle aus, die sich nicht mit Nachrichtentechnik ausführen.
Wenn das das ist, was man in dem Moment will, ich kenne das schon, das Gefühl, dass ich mich einfach mal über Computer unterhalten will. Irgendjemand sagte, war das auf dem Kongress? Nee, schon vorher. Thema Nummer eins. Wenn Thema Nummer eins dran ist, dann hat es meine Freundin halt schwer, aber damit muss sie leben.
Ich habe ihn gut verstanden. Ich meine, das ist...
Verständlich, das ist einfach nur unglaublich interessant mit den Computern. Da kann man sich nicht einfach die ganze Zeit über was weiß ich, das Wetter unterhalten oder so. Da gibt es einfach viel zu viele Informationen, die man austauschen muss.
Ja, also ob es beim Wetter irgendwie um andere Geschichten geht?
Natürlich.
Wie sind denn das andere Sachen?
Na, wir erforschen Maschinen.
Ob man sich Abkürzungen... Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio. Was willst du denn hören, Jan? Was würdest du denn lieber hören?
Ich höre lieber euch, weil ich schlafe einfach nur ein, wenn ihr das spielt.
Ja, endlich mal jemand, der das spielt.
Du bist anders als alle anderen. Die anderen schlafen ein, wenn sie uns nur hören.
Ja, ich finde es echt sehr interessant, was ihr immer erzählt. Ihr könnt es auch nicht öfter machen.
Aber es läuft doch kaum... Wir machen einmal im Monat, aber es läuft doch kaum Musik. Du hörst doch die ganze Zeit uns.
Ach, Quatsch. Ich hab vorhin die letzte halbe Stunde, aber bestimmt 90 Prozent Musik, wenn ich es nicht verschlafen habe.
Dann hast du einen falschen Sender drin gehabt. Oder du hast es tatsächlich verschlafen. Ich glaube, der Musikanteil in den letzten fast zwei Stunden war auf keinen Fall höher als 10.
Es ist ja natürlich auch immer so, dass Zeit sehr relativ ist. Also wie man sich veranschaulichen kann, so fünf Minuten auf der einen Seite der Klothöre und der anderen Seite der Klothöre sind schon ein echter Unterschied. Und wenn du nicht auf die Musik stehst, dann kommt dir natürlich der Musikteil länger vor. Aber es ist schon ausgewogen, was wir eben machen.
Trotzdem ist das eine Kritik, die wir durchaus mal annehmen können.
Ich kann da nur beifinden.
Ich freue mich schon auf Hip Hop Fritz nächste Woche.
Ich bin ja der festen... Das hat übrigens mit der Techno Woche auf Fritz nichts zu tun, dass wir hier Techno spielen, sondern...
Ja, ich merke schon, hat der letzte Mal auch schon...
Ja, machen wir eigentlich seit den drei Jahren inzwischen die Sendung anhand? Naja, also diese Musikdiskussion, die führen wir ja intern auch, aber irgendwann haben wir...
Wir spielen hier nicht Techno, wir spielen hier elektronische Musik.
So richtig Techno ist es nicht, nee.
Naja, das ist nun richtig Techno.
Also wir haben uns irgendwann so drauf geeinigt, wir reden über Technik, also spielen wir auch Technik, technische Musik, elektronische Musik. Ich kann mir durchaus auch Musik, die zum Computern passt, vorstellen, die nicht elektronisch ist, aber mal gucken. Vielleicht werden wir das noch machen. Das machen wir auch mal wieder. Ich werd mich doch mal wieder engagieren und dann machen wir das. Ich mach das auch mal. Ja, dann kommt ihr wieder mit der NDW-Scheiße an.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, seitdem es mehr deutschen Hip-Hop gibt, verstehe ich, warum es Hip-Hop überhaupt gibt und was die Leute daran finden. Also, aufgrund des Mainstreams amerikanischen Hip-Hop, das ist nämlich so alt, da hab ich das nie nachvollziehen können, aber da geht es eigentlich auch um Sprache und um Sprachwitz. Und da ist es halt besonders gelungen, wenn man etwas so sagt, dass es sich reimt. Da steckt halt sozusagen einmal das, was man sagt und dann die Art und Weise, wie man es sagt. Und das ist ja eigentlich beim Hacker-Jargon auch so, dass man sozusagen eine Information rüberbringen will und sich dann drüber freut, wenn man die auf der einen Seite kurz dringend rübergebracht hat und sich auf der anderen Seite auch auf das Konstrukt, das man verwendet hat, freuen kann.
Das war unglaublich schön ausgesucht.
Ausgedrückt, meine ich.
Ja, Hip-Hop ist sowieso nächste Woche. Dann übrigens auch in Svankern am Dienstag natürlich.
Wir können uns ja mal richtig elektronische Musik anhören, die der Herr ja aus dem Kopf hat.
Wir verteilen das einfach mal. Ich wähle mal die Musik aus für eine Sendung, dann wählt Tim mal die Musik aus für eine Sendung. Dann sagen wir immer, heute Musik ausgewählt von...
Von Stryny oder so.
So haben wir ja angefangen, aber ich denke, wir werden uns auch gerade in diesem Jahr noch mal sehr, gerade um das Thema Musik bemühen werden. Also weil Computer, Musik, Techno und so weiter, das hängt alles gut zusammen.
Man muss einfach mal das spielen, was man wirklich zu Hause, wenn man am Gerät sitzt, gerne hört. Und ich höre dann zum Beispiel durchaus gerne.
Ich kann dir mal vorspielen, was ich früher mal so gehört habe. Ich finde es ein Haufen Leute, die dann nein in Schnellzirnen, weil das Songtrick zu quake ist.
Ja, ich hab mal vorgestellt, ihr könnt ja einfach mal euren 50 CD wechseln und dann immer so in den einen Schacht Techno, in den nächsten Hip-Hop, in den nächsten Blaschart Mucke und dann macht ihr einfach noch ein bisschen Schaffel rein.
Ja, bloß, dass wir das natürlich mit Festplatten machen und nicht mit CD wechseln.
Und außerdem haben wir keinen 50 CD Wechseler.
Den haben wir 25.
Nicht mal den, wir haben drei ganz normale CD-Splatte. Dann kommt ein M-Pack drauf und dann geht das schon. Genau, Jan, aber die Musikdiskussion hält nicht an, versprochen.
Jetzt können wir uns mal anhören, wirst du uns am C64 früher alles anhören. Ja-Slang Es ist, es ist, es ist, also jetzt muss ich mal was sagen.
Lieber Firma Apple, es ist jetzt einfach Ende.
Dieses System ist einfach langsam und schlecht.
Ich hab kein Problem damit mit dem Abspielen von dem.
Ja, ja, das ist dieses Mac OS, das ist einfach zum heulen mit dem System.
Ach, ist echt mehr Zeit.
Wir wiederholen das mal.
Ich hab heute bei Tim ein Microsoft Windows NT CD liegen sehen.
Ja, in der Nähe vom Klo.
Wenn ich mehr Zeit hätte, würde ich auch Linux benutzen. Hallo?
Wer bist denn du?
Ja, ich bin nochmal Thomas.
Hallo.
Thomas, hallo.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur, weil ich gehört hab, dass du um die Musik ging, sagen, dass ich die super finde und würde mich freuen, wenn da irgendwelche Namen noch kämen. Also, welche Tracks das sind, welche Titel und so was, wenn das ganz kurz noch angesagt würde.
Das kann ich gar mal ansagen. Im Moment hören wir Detroit Techno von einem Sampler, der einfach nur Detroit Beyond the Third Wave heißt. Ist aus dem Jahr 96. Das ist ein sehr angenehmer Sampler, auf Astralbergs erschienen.
Ja, super.
Und wenn ihr das öfters machen könntet, denn die ganze Musik hat mir die ganze Zeit gut gefallen. Ja, und zur Abkürzung, mein Gott, also Abkürzung finde ich super. Und was ich nicht weiß, was da natürlich vorkommt, die Internetadressen, ist einfach HTML. Das ist immer so Sache, wo ich gar nicht weiß, was heißt das eigentlich, aber da einzipfe halt.
Hypertext Markup Language.
Alles klar.
Also im Grunde genommen von Hypertext, von den Verbindungen und dann Markup, markieren, Language, Sprache.
Manche Leute halten ja HTML für eine Layout-Sprache, aber das ist falsch.
Was heißt URL?
Ach, ich lasse mal so einen Rahmen, ja.
Unified Resource Locator.
Eine vereinheitliche Schreibung zur Findung von Ressourcen.
Dann können wir jetzt auch gleich noch Http erklären.
Http steht für Hypertext Transfer Protocol und ist einfach das nicht Transfer Protocol, aber es ist vielleicht auch schon egal.
Egal.
Ist es selbst.
Transfer auf jeden Fall ist das das Protokoll, was halt zwei Computer miteinander sprechen, während sie eine Webseite sozusagen laden. Also von dem Server zum Client. Und HTML ist das Format, in dem diese Datei erstellt ist, damit der Browser wiederum weiß, wie er das anzuzeigen hat.
Was soll wohl die Abkürzung sein, die wir alle am meisten benutzen? Wahrscheinlich OK, oder?
Also immer in einer generellen Sprache.
OK ist tatsächlich das Wort, was Sprachwissenschaftler herausgefunden haben, was die meiste Verbreitung hat in der Welt.
Ich glaube, da gibt es noch eins davor.
Oder redest du von Abkürzungen? Es gibt irgendwie diese Geschichte von einem Bahnschrank, Werder. Von All Clear.
Es gibt auch die Geschichte von dem Colonel der US-Armee, der sämtliche Befehle mit O Punkt K Punkt unterzeichnete. Ganz geklärt ist das nicht.
All Clear würde man ja wohl auch eher mit AC abkürzen, oder? Ey, Bahnschrankenwerder.
Das heißt Legastika.
Das ist nicht die Bahnschrankenwerder anrufen, sondern es ist ein Scherz.
Wenn ich mal in diesen Chats war, hat mich immer wieder genervt, oder auch bei E-Mails zunehmend genervt, dass durch diese Abkürzung, also LOL, das heißt ja Laughing Out Loud, glaube ich, und sich Grin und sowas, dann einfach Leute halt irgendwas geschrieben haben und denken, der Witz, den sie jetzt machen wird, ist der, dass sie einfach so eine kleine Abkürzung dahinter setzen.
Das sind dann Lamer.
Ich muss, ich benutze zum Beispiel super, super viel von diesen blöden Emoticons, diesen Smilies, also das kann jeder zu Hause, der auch nichts mit Computer hat, kann einen Doppelpunkt und eine Klammer zuschreiben und wenn er das Blatt dann nach rechts einmal dreht um 90 Grad, dann ist er ein Smiley. Die benutze ich viel zu viel, einfach weil ich immer Schiss habe, dass Leute mich falsch verstehen. Also bei allem, was ich so ein bisschen mit Augenzwinkern sage, irgendwie kommt da immer gleich dieses Ding dahinter. Wenn ich mir dann manchmal Mails angucke, denke ich, aber es ist auch wirklich schwierig, Sachen wegzulassen, weil speziell wenn man weiß, dass man eventuell auch einen Humor hat, den nicht jeder sofort versteht.
Naja, aber ich meine, vielleicht schreibst du hier auch noch normale Briefe und da musst du auch drauf achten. Kannst du auch überall ein kleines Zwinker noch hinsetzen.
Ja und dann stellst du zum Beispiel, ich weiß, ich rede jetzt schon wieder von Words und ich werde mich jetzt nicht verteidigen, warum ich das ab und an benutzen muss, aber das ist eine total erstaunliche Funktion und auch eine, die ich hasse. Irrwiderlich, oder? Du schreibst in Words einen Doppelpunkt und eine Klammer zu und was kommt? Auf einmal so ein komischer kleiner Smiley. Also der wird ersetzt. Ein richtiger Grafik-Smiley, voll eklig. Wir haben es echt genau nicht verstanden. Aber der schönste Smiley, finde ich ja, die 8 mit Klammer zu, der finde ich am süßesten. Ich finde den Punk Rocker gut, mit dem Gleichzeichen, dann eine 8, also Punk Rocker mit weit aufgerissenen Augen, dann eine 8 und dann ein P. Das ist ein Punk Rocker mit Iroquese, der die Augen weit aufgerissen hat und die Zunge drauf steckt. Thomas, dank dir. Versuch du noch mal, und wir nehmen noch hier ein Kleppchen.
Genau, ich geh noch ein bisschen mit seinem Macintosh.
Ihr könnt weiter anrufen, wenn ihr Fragen habt zu Abkürzungen oder zur Sprache im Internet oder zwischen Hackern oder im Chat. Dann ruft uns an, 0331, Bepotztamm, 7097110.
Das ist die Telefonnummer hier.
Und dann muss man einfach nur noch warten, bis irgendeine Stimme im Telefon sagt, hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, ich würde gern in Blumenohne eine Frage stellen.
Jo, kannst du machen, bist schon drauf. Ja, das ist hier... Graz-Fatz geht das hier, hab ich schon mit an.
Hallo, ich bin Ralf. Ich hab mal eine Frage. Was kann ich verstehen, wenn von einem Ping die Rede ist?
Ah, genau, gute Frage. Ein Leben, den gibt's einen Pong.
Denen nur einen Ping.
Ich lasse später.
Die Pings kommen eigentlich von den U-Booten, von den Sonaten, wo man einen Sound losgeschickt hat, der halt wie ein Ping klingt und dann kommt nach einer Weile ein Ping zurück, was von dem U-Boot reflektiert wurde und aus der Laufzeit kann man messen, wie weit das weg ist. Und so ähnlich ist das halt auch bei TCP-IP. Man schickt ein spezielles Paket los, das heißt offiziell ICMP-Echo-Request, aber kein Mensch nennt das so, man nennt das ein Ping-Paket. Und was der Rechner macht, der dieses Paket kommt, ist da einfach ein Timestamp reintun, ein Stempel und einen ICMP-Echo-Reply zurückzuschicken. Und aus der Laufzeit kann man halt messen, wie weit der andere Rechner weg ist, beziehungsweise ob er überhaupt da ist. Und auch das wird wiederum für nicht Computer verwandt. Man kann dann zum Beispiel Leute anpingen, damit sie ihre Aufmerksamkeit auf einen richten oder zu wissen, ob sie da sind. Also ich pinge mal den und den an, heißt ich guck mal nach, ob der da ist, wenn er da ist oder so weiter.
Genau, und das Programm, mit dem man das macht, heißt eben pingen. Naja, wenn du wissen willst, du versuchst jetzt eine Verbindung, eine Netzwerkverbindung zu einem anderen Computer aufzubauen, über Web zum Beispiel, irgendein Webserver und da kommt nichts. Dann machst du ein Telnet auf zu irgendeinem Rechner, wo du eine Shell drauf haben kannst oder du hast selbst ein Unix-System, wo es den Ping-Befehl gibt oder ein Ping-Programm auf dem Mac oder auf dem Windows-Rechner und dann sagst du ping diesen Rechner und dann kriegst du auf relativ niedriger Ebene mit, ob dieser Rechner überhaupt vorhanden ist, ob der im Netz ist, ob der eingeschaltet ist und ob der theoretisch antworten kann. Und wie lange es dauert, bis dein Paket wieder zurückgekommen ist, d.h. du weißt, es ist einfach nur verdammt viel los im Internet und das dauert halt jetzt. Oder du weißt, nein, dieser Rechner ist down, der ist nicht verfügbar. Du fragst so spezifisch, wird das benutzt von jemandem, den du kennst in der Mail oder so?
Nee, ich hab ein Problem und zwar, ich hatte mir aus dem Netz ein Programm runtergeladen und hab dann nach ein paar Tagen festgestellt, dass irgendwas mit meinem Rechner nicht stimmt. Und dann habe ich mir Lektüre gekauft, nämlich die Datenschutz-CP, die ist der Hacker Best Friend, und dachte, naja, ich guck mal nach, ob ich irgendwie verseucht worden bin. Und dann habe ich in der Beschreibung von BO gelesen, wie man feststellen kann, ob man BO auf dem Rechner hat. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, in diesem Zusammenhang habe ich ping gelesen, das wäre meine nächste Frage, aber wenn das nichts mit dem Thema zu tun hat, wie kriege ich, wenn ich diesen drojaner BO auf meinem Rechner habe, wie kriege ich den wieder runter?
Linux installieren.
Ihr sollt nicht lachen, ihr sollt mir helfen.
Ja, sowohl als auch.
Sowohl als Witz gemeint, als auch ernst gemeint, weil Windows ist einfach schlecht und Windows hat keine Sicherheitsmechanismen und das kriegst du ja zwar immer weg. Und dann kommt aber das nächste Tool, das heißt ein NetBus, und dann kommt wieder noch ein Tool. Und bei Windows hast du einfach überhaupt gar keine Sicherheit und die einzige Chance ist, dieses Windows loszuwerden.
Also gibt es jetzt einen direkten Tipp für ihn? Ich kenne diesen Virus, oder ein drojanisches Pferd, oder was ist das?
Das ist ein Trojaner, der sich halt einlistet im System und dann irgendwie bequem ins Netz hinein einfach Verbindungen anbietet. Und man kann dann mit einem entsprechenden Client, mit dem Backorifive Client einfach an diese Maschine sich randocken und so ziemlich alles fernsteuern, was man möchte. Die ganze Registry auslesen.
Moment mal, heißt das jetzt jeder? Oder ist derjenige, der mit dem Geschicht sagt, kann meinen Rechner fernsteuern wie mit Lab Link?
Ja, genau das.
Nur ein bisschen besser.
Noch komfortabler, noch schneller und noch üblicher.
Hey, ich hab eine Atompompe auf meinem Rechner.
Genau, sie heißt Windows.
Sag mal, ich hab jetzt gerade nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Wo hast du das hergekriegt? Was für ein Programm hast du runtergeladen?
Also ich hab es aus dem Netz runtergeladen. Das weiß ich inzwischen. Aber ich weiß nicht, in welchem Pfeil das Ding versteckt war. Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es bei euch Erfahrungswerte hier im Studio?
Na ja, es ist ein trojanisches Pferd. Es nistelt sich halt in irgendwelche Programme ein. Man weiß halt nicht, welches damit infiziert ist. Man startet ein Programm und dann hat man einen Back-Ore-Pfeil. Das ist halt die Eigenschaft eines trojanischen Pferdes.
Wie kann das überhaupt nicht identifizieren, gar nicht finden?
Also du kannst ja die Gängen den aktuellen Vien-Scanner holen, die sind in der Lage, das zu finden. Du kannst auch einfach, wenn du dich halbwegs auskennst, mal in die Registry reingucken und dann... Gibt es da in den Start-Up-Pfeils einen Eintrag, bei dem das Ding gestartet wird, wenn du den Rechner hochfährst?
Du kannst auch einfach eine der üblichen Suchmaschinen aufmachen und Back-Ore-Pfeils eintippen und dann wirst du irgendwie voll zugeschüttet mit Möglichkeiten, wie du das Programm nutzen, entfernen, installieren, jemandem unterjubeln, an was nicht noch alles machen kannst.
Und der Norton-Antivirus erkennt das Ding nicht?
Das kommt auf die Version an, glaube ich. Die neueste kann das sicher. Viel Spaß noch mit ihm. Ich hoffe, wir haben dir ein bisschen geholfen. Oh, da hat er heute eine lange Nacht, aber nicht nach.
Viel Spaß.
Immer so viel zu lachen. Kann jemand in kurzem erklären, was ein trojanisches Pferd ist? Genau.
Also es ist nicht das, was in Film 23 als trojanisches Pferd erklärt wird. Das war vielleicht vorab.
Ja, genau.
Ein trojanisches Pferd, als trojanisches Pferd bezeichnet man den Mechanismus eines Programms, sich in einem anderen Programm zu verstecken, mit ihm durch ein Tor gelassen zu werden, Download auf die Festplatte und dort bei der Aktivierung des Programms sich selber entfalten zu können. So wie halt damals die Krieger rein sind ins Pferd, das Pferd ist dann irgendwie nach Troja reingeschoben worden und da drin sprangen dann irgendwie auf einmal ganz ruppige Jungs raus. Und das ist halt auch mit Backorifice und vielen anderen Programmen. Also Backorifice ist halt jetzt super bekannt, weil es funktioniert prima, es gibt auch noch Netvus, es macht was ähnliches. Man kann sich dieses Programm natürlich auch selber runterladen und starten, ohne dass man es als trojanisches Pferd verpackt bekommt.
Und was damit anstellbar ist, haben wir gerade gehört. Hier fragt gerade im Chat jemand, wofür TCP-IP steht.
Ah, ja das ist richtig.
Transmission Control Protocol Schrägstrich Internet Protocol. Also IP steht nicht etwa für eine Zahl, die mit vielen Punkten drin ist, sondern IP steht für Internet Protocol. Man hat keine IP, sondern eine IP-Adresse. Und allein dadurch, dass man diesen Unterschied weiß, erkennt man auch schon Leute, die wissen, wovon sie reden. Also wenn einer sagt, ich hab die und die IP, dann weiß man, aha, aha, neu und... Der nächste Punkt, wo man dann die Leute erkennt, ist, wenn sie sagen, der Rechner hat eine IP-Adresse, weil nämlich eigentlich die Netzwerke hat eine IP-Adresse, man kann auch drei haben, dann hat man drei IP-Adressen und...
Man kann auch mehrere IP-Adressen auf einer.
Man kann auch mehrere auf einer Adresse haben, aber der Punkt ist einfach, dass es auch wieder ein typisches Beispiel dafür ist, wie man durch Sprache etwas ausdrückt und wie man es vor allen Dingen korrekt ausdrücken muss, um sozusagen dazu zu gehören, um den Slang zu sprechen. Aber ja, das war ein bisschen abgeschweifend, aber TCPIP Transmission Control Protocol ist dann sozusagen ein Protokoll, das auf dem Internetprotokoll aufsetzt, eine Datenverbindung erlaubt, wo man dann auf der einen Seite was reintut und es kommt auf der anderen Seite raus. Also genau genommen ist es auch unvollständig, weil tatsächlich sind TCP und IP nur zwei Protokolle aus der sogenannten Internetprotokollsuit, also der gesamten Sammlung aller im Internet gesprochenen Protokolle. IP ist eben das Wichtigste, weil darauf basiert alles. IP-Router sind die Maschinen, die halt IP von links nach rechts schieben und die das Netz ausmachen, also die die Daten überhaupt erst verteilen, in die richtige Richtung schicken. TCP ist halt eines der Protokolle, die man dann auf IP fährt. Aber es ist beileibe das Wichtigste, weil sehr viele Sachen, die man gut kennt, wie zum Beispiel HTTP, setzen wiederum darauf auf. Aber es gibt auch noch ein anderes zum Beispiel UDP, aber das wird jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit.
Das gab gerade noch die Frage. FDP sollte man auch gleich noch kurz erwähnen.
Fyltransfer Protokoll. Das ist eine der ersten beiden Protokolle im Internet überhaupt. Also neben dem IP lag ich unten, dann gibt es TCP und UDP da drüber. Und dann hat man angefangen mit dieser Internet Protokoll für Programme zu schreiben, also Dienste, Services. Und FDP und Telnet waren die ersten beiden Services, die als erstes gemacht wurden. Also mit FDP konnte man Dateien übertragen, mit Telnet konnte man sich an einem anderen Computer anmelden und ihn aus der Ferne benutzen. Das war auch erstmal der erste Sinn mit dem Internet.
Wir fragen weiter nach euren Anrufen. Ihr könnt uns Fragen stellen nach Abkürzungen. Ich hab eigentlich gedacht, dass viel mehr Fragen kommen, was so die Chat-Abkürzungen angeht, weil das ja doch immer noch ein sehr beliebter und immer beliebter werdender Service des Internets ist. Und ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass viele Leute da mit diesen ganzen Abkürzungen nicht so viel anzufangen wissen. Wenn wir lachen, dann lachen wir nur, weil wir Spaß haben. Aber wir lachen euch nicht aus. Also es gibt nichts, was ihr uns nicht fragen könnt. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, also ich hab, bevor ich jetzt zu meiner kleinen Abkürzung komme, übrigens kenne ich das nicht als trojanisches Pferd, sondern als Linkvirus. Ist doch richtig, oder? Ist doch ein Linkvirus, was wir vorhin mitbrachten haben.
Nein, nein, Back Oriface ist ein trojanisches Pferd. Es verbreitet sich nicht, sondern es installiert sich halt einmal auf dem Rechner und es hängt an einem anderen Programm dran. Das gibt es auch als Standalone-Version, aber es zeichnet sich halt dadurch aus, dass wenn es downloadet ausführt, dann passiert erstmal nichts. Also nichts, was man sehen würde. Und dann kann man halt vom Netz auch darauf zugreifen, es macht also etwas anderes, als es vorgibt zu tun.
Also direkt vom Programm VIRUS wahrscheinlich so vorgesehen worden, denke ich mal. Natürlich. Also nicht ein VIRUS, was sich an irgendein Programm hinten dran klingt und dann irgendwelche bösen Sachen macht, sondern direkt das Programm selbst ist eigentlich ein VIRUS, bloß man merkt nicht, dass es ein VIRUS ist.
Das ist der falsche Begriff dafür. VIRUS heißt, dass es sich von Programm zu Programm verbreitet. Und das tut das nicht.
Das dupliziert dich nicht. Du bist selber schuld, wenn du das hast.
Der Name VIRUS... Vielleicht eine gute Gelegenheit, die Sache mit VIRUS und so weiter zu erklären. VIRUS ist bei Leibe der verbreitetste Begriff für etwas, was auf dem eigenen Computer landet und dort etwas tut, was man eigentlich gar nicht wollte. Und VIRUSen heißen deshalb VIREN wegen ihrer Art und Weise der Fortpflanzung. Sie listen sich eben in Programmen ein, werden dort aktiv und verbreiten sich auf das nächste Programm und so weiter. Es gibt auch noch andere Programmschemen. Und das eine ist zum Beispiel, also Verbreitungsschemen, das hatten wir eben schon, der Trojaner, der sich in einem anderen Programm einlistet, sich irgendwo hintragen lässt und dann ist er da. Und dann gibt es auch noch WIRMA, das sind Programme, die sich selbstständig über das Netz verbreiten, von Rechner zu Rechner. Man kann natürlich das auch alles beliebig kombinieren und das dann auf einen einzelnen Begriff zu bringen. Dieses Programm macht jetzt das und das. Das weiß man eh nicht bei WIRN, die machen halt irgendwas. Und was sie tun, naja.
Das sollte ja nicht sein. Ja, meine Abkürzung.
TOS ist von Atari das Operating System. Eigentlich Tremial Operating System.
Ja, genau falsch.
Nein, langsam, langsam, langsam. Das ist eigentlich Tremial Operating System. Aber ursprünglich, also die böse Zungen behaupten, dass das damals anders gewesen ist mit dem Jack Famile. Tim hatte da glaube ich mal eine Story zu.
War das nicht auch Star Trek?
Na ja, also TOS heißt ja eigentlich das Operating System.
Ja, das ist so wilder bei der Sache mit den Wahrheiten. Ich glaub, dass der Tremille, das ist ein ziemlich verschmitzter kleiner Kerl gewesen, der fand das schon ziemlich cool, dass das alle Tremille Operating System genannt haben. Das ist ein Scheißsystem.
Entschuldigung, bitte.
Na ja, der TOS im Kern war nichts anderes als ein auf 68K umgeschriebenes DOS. Und was wir davon zu halten haben, die hatten genau die gleichen Trepps und all den ganzen Krempel, die haben sich nichts einfallen lassen, auch nicht mal ein eigenes Datei-System. Genau.
Ja, also Windows ist bestimmt nicht mehr nützend. Ich hab noch ein paar Abkürzungen, DFÜ-Abkürzungen, Rotfl zum Beispiel, ROTFL.
Ah, wir sind beim Titel der Sendung gesagt.
Das ist eigentlich unser Arbeitszitel gewesen.
Rolling on the floor laughing.
Yo, dann haben wir noch RTFMA. Was?
Read the fucking manual asshole?
Und was gibt's noch? Oh, PEP gibt's.
Was heißt das?
Also ich kann jetzt nicht so Englisch ausbreiten. Wir wissen nicht, was das heißt. Keine Ahnung. Und dann auch POV, Point of View, Standpunkt Einstellung zu etwas.
BKW muss man auch mal sagen. Genau.
Kennt ihr da noch was, wo ihr die Abkürzung nicht kennt? Ich hab hier einen Lexikon vor mir.
Sag mal was TOC heißt.
Table of Contents steht drin.
Table of Contents.
Ich meine, viele Begriffe haben ja auch mehrere Übersetzungen. Die Frage ist halt immer, welche ist jetzt eigentlich die, die sich im Hacker-Slang wirklich eingebürgert hat und von mehr als nur einer Person, weil sie es gerade im Buch gefunden hat, benutzt.
Was ich hier oft lese, ist immer Imho oder Immo oder sowas.
Genau, das hatten wir vorhin in my humble opinion, also nach meiner unwichtigen Meinung.
Oder auch nur Imho.
Was natürlich auch super wichtig ist, ist FAQ.
Häufig gestellte Fragen.
Das ist glaube ich ein Begriff, der es wirklich noch in den Mainstream schaffen wird. Weil das Prinzip der FAQ ist so effektiv für Informationsverbreitung, dass ich denke, dass sie auch FAQ irgendwie weit aus dem Internet herausbewegen wird. Dass die Firmen zu irgendeinem Produktkatalog oder auch gleich eine FAQ hinten reinpacken und die dann auch so nennen werden. Weil einfach der Begriff steht und es gibt dafür kein bester. Wir nennen sie ja dann immer die FAQ, was wir darunter verstehen mögen.
Richard, ich sag dir schon mal Tschüss und vielen Dank. Wir können natürlich weiter anrufen. 031-FATSTAM-77-97-110, wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Ich hatte zum einen eine Frage, eine der Studio-Gäste hatte erwähnt, den Router.
Ah, haben wir vorhin auch drüber geredet.
Heißt das Router oder Router kommt jetzt?
Genau, ich hab da Englisch Routing angekommen.
Ja, das sag ich auch immer, wir haben es rausgefunden. Das ist natürlich wieder die verhohene Piepeldung der englischen Sprache von den Amerikanern. Also es heißt eigentlich Routing, aber die Amis sagen Routing, das gilt beides.
Also die Amerikaner benutzen meines Wissens beides und die Engländer benutzen Routing.
Ah ja, es ist ein Router und es ist ein Routing.
Das klingt irgendwie mehr nach, ist politisch.
Klingt mehr nach, ich weiß Bescheid.
Was, wenn man Router sagt?
Wenn man Router sagt.
Meinst du?
Ich finde, das klingt total Disco.
Das ist glaube ich der genialste Ausdruck, den ich seit langem gehört habe.
Hut ab, das klingt Disco.
Großartig, das werde ich benutzen ab jetzt.
Ich hatte vorhin noch nach Witzen von Hacker, beziehungsweise Computer Club, gesucht. Ich habe mal neulich eine ganz hübsche Sache gefunden. Vorhin nannte sich Berufsprofile oder wie jagt man Elefanten. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, da geht es darum, der Informatiker oder Programmierer jagt eben Elefanten so, dass er unten der Cup der guten Hoffnung anfängt und sich eben mal links-rechts pendelt, durch Afrika bewegt, alles fängt, nachguckt, ist es ein Elefant und irgendwann dann in Cairo irgendwie ihn terminiert. Der Harde-Programmierer stellt dann noch einen bekannten Elefanten in Cairo auf, um sicherzustellen, dass wirklich der Algorithmus terminiert. Das geht dann noch eine Weile so weiter, also über den Assembler-Programmierer, der den Algorithmus noch in Stien fortsetzt, den Kobol-Programmierer, der das auf den Dinosaurier macht, den Basic-Programmierer, der einen mit Sand ausgepolsterten Einspender bevorzugt, bei dem die Handbremse ständig angezogen wird. Dann gab es noch den C-Programmierer, der bestimmt erst mal mit Size auf die Speichergröße eines Elefanten, vergisst dann aber den Speicher wieder freizugeben und schießt mit blöden Pointern um sich, bis er den Elefanten trifft. Der C++-Programmierer, der alte Elefant sei ja ein Objekt und müsse seine Fang-Methode selber mitbringen. Da gab es noch Microsoft, die kaufen einen Elefanten aus dem Zoo in Seattle, kopieren ihn massenhaft, sagen, es wäre die ideale Ergänzung zu Office und verkaufen 60 Millionen Stück nach Afrika. So viel zum Wissen unter Hacker.
Das hat super funktioniert.
Der Elefant muss seine Fang-Methode selber mitbringen.
Ja, damit auch vielen Dank an dich.
Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Kein mehr.
Hallo, wer ist da?
Willst du weiter leiser machen?
Leiser?
Im Moment gibt es noch nicht, scheint okay zu sein.
Aber ich war mich nicht so gerne selber im Radio, glaube ich. Und zwar bin ich so ein richtiger Computer-User im Augenblick. Ich habe das früher immer mehr betrieben. Aber ich denke, ich nur eine Frage, weil ich habe gerade über Macintosh und so. Ich habe meinen alten Macintosh noch und soll mir jetzt einen neuen kaufen. Ist das jetzt gar nicht zu empfehlen oder so, weil da gerade so ein lustig drüber gemacht worden ist?
Nee, da sind wir jetzt natürlich in einem völlig anderen Thema. Tim hat hier ein bisschen Probleme mit seinem Powerbook, weil es die Soundfiles nicht so ausspielt, wie er gerne hätte.
Also der Punkt ist einfach, PCs sind noch schlechter.
Genau, das war eigentlich meine Erfahrung bislang.
Ja, ja, daran will ich auch nicht rütteln. Also ich meine, die Alternative heißt auf gar keinen Fall PC.
Also nur weil der Mac nicht gut ist, heißt das nicht, dass der PC nicht noch schlecht ist. Außerdem muss man jetzt kurz langsam machen, weil du redest hier natürlich mit Leuten, die diesen Computer, was auch immer für eine Mark oder was auch immer für ein Betriebssystem erfährt, bis in die Abgründe benutzen sozusagen.
Ja, ich will einfach, dass man viel zuverlässiger ist.
Also er ist auf jeden Fall zuverlässiger als ein PC.
Als Empfehlung nach draußen ist es auf jeden Fall, nach wie vor die Wahl für Endanwender, gar keine Frage. Nur, es ist eben so, wenn man sich so intensiv mit einem Rechner auseinander setzt, dass man im Prinzip die ganze Zeit damit arbeitet, dann entwickeln sich gewisse Erwartungshaltungen, die diese Systeme eigentlich nie erfüllen können.
Also mit diesem iMac macht es natürlich schon Sinn, ins Netz zu gehen und damit komme ich ganz gut klar. Ja, weil ich bin ja jetzt noch ein bisschen außen vor. Ich kann natürlich lauschen, eigentlich total gerne, oftige Weise, obwohl ich damit nicht so viel anfangen kann. Aber die Sendung über Music on Demand oder so.
Also kauft ihr ein iMac und du lernst was über das Internet, kauft ihr ein PC und du lernst was über PC-Kartenkonfigurationen, Isar-Busse, irgendwie Jumper-Konfigurationen.
Blutende Finger, genau.
Kauft ihr PC und Linux drauf.
Ich habe mir meinen LC2 gekauft und der ist auch sehr zuverlässig. Der hat mir eigentlich bislang gereicht als Schreibmaschine. Mehr brauche ich eigentlich auch nicht.
Dann wirst du auf jeden Fall von der Geschwindigkeit vom iMac umgehauen sein. Der iMac ist ganz, ganz, ganz prima, nur zu teuer. Eigentlich wäre der zu teuer. Wenn er 500 Mark billiger wäre, wäre er richtig cool. Dann wäre er richtig, richtig cool, natürlich.
Das ist echt ein Punkt.
Aber na gut, ich meine, was solls.
Bevor er losgeht und für 2000 Mark einen PC mit 30.000 Kabeln und Einzelteilen kauft und dann irgendwie den anschaltet und es funktioniert nicht, ist ja einmal kein Fehler.
Das ist bei Freunden so, ich hab immer gesagt, das erbastelt ja nur, er arbeitet ja gar nicht damit.
Du kriegst für das gleiche Geld beim PC nichts Besseres. Das kann man einfach so sagen.
Dann bin ich ja beruhigt, also nicht, dass ich gerade mein Scheiß wüsste.
Das ist auf jeden Fall was billigeres, da hab ich gar keine Zweifel. Was billigeres findest du auf jeden Fall.
Aber ob das das ist, was du haben möchtest, das wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Dann werde ich mal warten, weil ich dir jetzt noch ein bisschen billiger werde, weil dir eine neue Serie drauf kommt.
Das ist das Beste beim Computerkauf. Warten.
Also ich sag mal, in 10 Jahren die Computer nennen.
Da haben wir Sachen zu erwarten.
Ich warte auch noch.
Dann könntet ihr eure Aufkauf und eure Gebrauchten kaufen.
Genau, ich kann dir da echt günstig eintun.
Ich hab da noch ein bisschen Sumpfland in Florida, Bauland.
Dann lass ich mal lieber die qualifizierten Fragen jetzt mal durch.
Ich fand die überhaupt nicht unqualifiziert.
Alles klar.
Das interessiert mich nur so, weil ich jetzt immer nur so mitkriege, Internet und so.
Ich glaub, da komm ich nicht drum rum jetzt.
Markus, dank dir. Dankeschön, tschüss.
Tatsächlich scheint das ja wie in der Werbung zu funktionieren. Habt ihr noch nicht von jemandem gehört, der sein Erstcomputer war, tatsächlich ein iMac. Der hat in 5 Minuten oder in 10 Minuten, wie auch immer, 15 Minuten von mir aus seinen Internetzugang hingekriegt, wo man früher stundenlange Gespräche mit Freunden am Telefon hatte. Nee, dann ruf nochmal das andere auf. Jetzt gibst du da 194 Punkte, 64 Punkte. Hä, was, wo kommt der Punkt und so? Und es scheint tatsächlich doch inzwischen mit diesen Internet-Dings da.
Was wäre dann die Alternative für Windows?
Eigentlich wollen wir darüber jetzt nicht weiter reden.
Okay, hier sagen wir ein Betriebssystem, der bei CoreOS sicher ist.
Wir können das ja jetzt noch einmal kurz verschöpft verhandeln. Windows taugt nichts, Mac OS ist irgendwie die bessere Wahl. Aber wenn du ein richtiges Betriebssystem haben willst, wo du dich sehr tief auseinandersetzen kannst, wenn dich das interessiert, dann könntest du zu Linux oder einer BSD-Variante greifen.
BSD, genau, Free BSD oder NetBS. Man muss unbedingt dazu sagen, obwohl ich Linux benutze, im Moment selber nicht, hat das aber schon auf PCs installiert. Und obwohl ich das liebe, vor allen Dingen die ganze Philosophie dahinter, ist es ein Betriebssystem, mit dem du arbeiten musst. Du musst dich damit auseinandersetzen, du musst wissen, was da passiert. Ja, gut, du kannst inzwischen einfache Installationen haben und so, aber... Dann läuft ein Staroffice und dann schreibst du einfach, dass klappt. Ich hab neulich ein komplettes Linux bis zur grafischen Oberfläche X Windows mit Staroffice in 20 Minuten installiert.
Und dann schreibst du und drückst und es funktioniert inzwischen.
Aber, ihr seid zu weit weg von Leuten, die sich einen Computer kaufen. Da hab ich glaube ich hier mal Enter und einmal die IP-Nummer eingegeben. Also ich denke, wenn du keine Ahnung vorher von Computern hast, ist das irgendwie was, den Windows oder Mac OS einsteckt, genauso wie das, wie das aus dem Linux reinsteckt. Mittlerweile. Man muss dann hinterher. Das ist halt irgendwie eine andere Herangehensweise im Prinzip. Wir kriegen gleich den Betriebssystem Stress hier.
Also wir reden über Hacker-Slang.
Was mach ich hier? Da kannst du auch Linux darauf installieren, wenn du Bock drauf hast und der Computer funktioniert wenigstens.
Wenn all deine Kumpels einen PC haben. Wenn alle deine Kumpels und alle, die du kennst, einen PC haben, wirklich alle, und du da Wert drauf liest, dann kauf dir auch einen PC. Wenn du wirklich genug Leute hast, die du fragen kannst und wenn du Lust hast, wirklich viel Zeit damit zu verschwenden, dann kauf dir auch einen PC und dann tu auch ein Microsoft-Betriebssystem drauf und versuche damit glücklich zu werden. Aber wenn du unbedarft rangehst, kaum Leute kennst und einfach mit dem Ding arbeiten willst, dann kauf dir einen Mac und wenn du wirklich tief einsteigen willst, dann tu dir einen Linux drauf.
Und wenn du Windows nimmst und du wirst nicht glücklich, ruf uns nicht an.
So, jetzt fangen wir mal zum Schluss an, richtige Aussagen. Liebe Herr.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal selber ein bisschen wieder auf den Slang kommen.
Ja, wir müssen unbedingt wieder zurück zum Slang.
Vielleicht machen wir ein paar Sachen ein, die wir noch vergessen haben.
Sag mal.
Weißt du, was ein rekursives Akronym ist?
Ach, verdammt, ich glaube, das hatten wir hier schon mal in der Sendung. Du musst das nochmal erklären.
Also es gibt da ein Projekt, das nennt sich GNU, das ist ja sehr bekannt.
Es steht wofür?
Ja, GNU steht für GNU is not Unix.
Aber wofür steht GNU?
GNU steht für GNU is not Unix. Es ist ein rekursives Akronym, es ruft sich immer wieder selber auf. Und das ist ein Witz an sich, weil Rekursion in der Programmierung halt ein wichtiges Element ist. Dass Funktionen sich wieder selbst aufrufen können und so weiter. Wenn man sich nicht mehr aufruft, dann geht das alles wieder zurück. Bei GNU geht das natürlich ewig weiter. Und das nennt man eben ein Rekursives Akronym, was ein besonderer Wortwitz ist, dem die Szene entwickelt hat, weil da eben Rekursion drin ist.
Das kann man nicht erklären, das ist halt einfach komisch.
Und es gibt viele Abkürzungen mittlerweile, die halt diese Rekursion benutzen, einfach diese GNU-Idee aufgreifen.
Mittlerweile gibt es sogar schon einen Begriff.
Es gibt ein neues Betriebssystem, das heißt HURD. H-U-R-D. Ich muss mich da nochmal nachschlanken.
Wir machen vielleicht, ich fühle kurz die Brücke mit Joe.
Es gibt einen Editor, der heißt Joe und der heißt natürlich, eigentlich ist das Joe's Own Editor. Und das ist wieder Joe's Own Editor und das ist Joe's Own Editor und so weiter.
Also HURD, H-U-R-D, steht für, so heißt es in der Beschreibung, HURD of Unix Replacing Demons. Wobei sich dieses HURD in H-I-R-D schreibt. Jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, was heißt HIRD? H-I-R-D heißt HURD of Interfaces Representing Deaths. Wobei hier HURD wiederum mit U geschrieben ist, womit wir wieder am Anfang sitzen. Das ist sozusagen ein Paar von gegenseitig regressiven Akronymen.
Doch, doch. Ich wollte vorher das Mikro ausmachen. Was gibt es da bei diesem Grin vorhin mit Sternchen oder mit eckiger Klammer? G für Grin, dann gibt es EG für Evil Grin, dann gibt es Big Grin wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt vor allem viele Abkürzungen, die aus den Bedürfnissen der damaligen Zeit erwachsen sind. Die ersten Chats, die ersten Netzverbindungen haben die Leute in der Regel mit 300 Bits pro Sekunde Geschwindigkeit betrieben, mit Akustikkopplern oder mit 300 BPS Modems.
Das ist nicht sehr schnell, da kann man schön zu sehen, übrigens um 23, wo dann ein leichtes Lachen durch den Kinosaal geht, wenn der Telefonhörer, der Telefon natürlich mit Wählscheibe, auf diesen Akustikkoppler aufgeploppt wird.
Genau, wobei der Carrier war irgendwie nicht richtig. Das war kein richtiger Carrier.
Außerdem war der Aufkleber viel zu neu.
Den gab es damals noch gar nicht.
Aber das stimmt. Wenn man dann halt gechattet hat, dann kam noch die Verzögerung durch das Netz selber hinzu, weil die Computer damals auch alle nicht so schnell waren wie heute. So dass wenn man jetzt mit jemanden, sagen wir mal, in Australien gechattet hat oder so, dann kamen halt die Buchstaben so öff öff öff, einer nach dem anderen. Wenn man jetzt irgendwas langes ausdrücken will, was man sowieso immer wieder sagt, wie zum Beispiel in My humble opinion, dann nimmt man einfach eine Abkürzung. Das ging dann sogar so weit, dass auch andere, dass auch Ziffern mit einbezogen wurden und ihr Lautklang sozusagen mit rein nimmt. Das kann man im Deutschen ganz gut zeigen. Gute Nacht kann ich auch schreiben als gute, N und dann eine Acht. Und dann hab ich halt gute Nacht. Solche Abkürzungen gibt es also massenhaft. See you later. C-U-L8-E-R.
Oder einfach nur C-U für see you.
Oder C-U für see you.
Wobei ich am schönsten in dem Zusammenhang mit Zahlen, da sei übrigens auch ein Print erwähnt, der das in der Musik früh gemacht hat.
Also I would die for you.
Irgendwie so eine Geschichte mit zwei und vier. Und am allerschönsten finde ich dann eigentlich die Verbindung mit einem deutschen Wort, aber die Zahl englisch ausgesprochen. Bei dem Wort später zum Beispiel, was ich echt liebe. Also SP8R.
Also später.
Bis später oder so.
Also es gibt wirklich ein paar Sachen, die extrem nett sind, finde.
Ich. Es gibt eine wenig populäre Gruppe von Leuten, die man einfach als Wheres-Dudes bezeichnet. Wheres-Dudes sind halt nur die Kids, die irgendwie die ganzen Netze zunächst anderen benutzen, als einfach sich geklaute Raubkopierstoffe durch die Gegend zu tragen.
Also Wheres.
Hinten mit Z natürlich.
Und die Dudes mit zwei O.
Ja und so Q-Dudes schreiben die dann irgendwie K3WLD00DZ. So irgendwie. Das ist so die Abkürzungs... sind nicht besonders beliebt bei den Hackern, aber die gibt es halt auch und die haben halt da irgendwie besonders viel Spaß, das alles miteinander zu verzahnen. Das ist ja auch eine... das ist ja auch Ausdruck ihrer Kultur. Das muss man auch positiv... auf jeden Fall positiv herausstreichen. Die entwickeln ihre eigene Sprache, ihre eigene Ästhetik, auch an Dingen so Gefallen zu finden, mit denen sie sich auseinandersetzen. Daraus entwickeln sich wiederum neue Sachen.
Und auch das wird sich durchsetzen.
Also in bestimmten...
Das wird auf jeden Fall noch mal hip werden.
Mal als Überschrift für einen Lifestyle-Artikel. Snowboarding mit einer Drei auf dem Rücken und so eine Geschichte statt W.
Hacker machen ziemlich häufig Sexparties. Das ist nicht so bekannt in der Öffentlichkeit.
Das glaube ich auch jetzt einfach mal nicht.
Sexparties wird halt eine ganze Menge Software Exchange. Das zeigt aber auch schon, dass Hacker zu so sexuellen Sachen und so Sachen, die mit so zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen zu tun haben, sowieso eine sehr merkwürdige Einstellung haben. Da gibt es zum Beispiel, also Frauen hatten wir ja vorhin auch, das sind ja die fernen Wesen, die es am Anfang gar nicht gab. Das ändert sich jetzt zunehmend. Es gibt dann diesen schönen Begriff Motors. Motors heißt Members of the Opposite Sex. Das sind die Leute, die halt irgendwie der jeweiligen anderen Geschlecht angehören. So kann man das relativ ausdrücken.
Dann gibt es übrigens auch noch MOTSS, was dann wieder bedeutet Members of the Same Sex.
Richtig.
Was gibt es in dem Zusammenhang?
Und dann gibt es auch noch das, was wir irgendwie als Ehefrauen bezeichnen würden, heißt da einfach nur SO. Für Significant Other.
Das wird ein ekelhafter Begriff, finde ich, den die Amis tatsächlich auch so im Sprachgebrauch benutzen. Ich glaube, der kommt aus einem Real-Life-Sprachgebrauch ins Internet, weil man hat irgendwann festgestellt, dass Fiancé für Verlobter oder so, dass das alles doof ist für die Arten von Ehen, die wir führen, wenn man länger zusammen ist. Und deswegen ist es dann der SO, my SO, my significant other.
Die bessere Hälfte.
Ganz scheiße.
Der wichtige andere.
Lebensabschnittsgefährte. Hier ist eine, wenn auch völlig falsche, aber doch sehr witzige Erklärung für die Abkürzung Apple. Arrogance produces profit losing entity. Musikjurorien zwar, vorhin jemand angefragt hat ja immer noch von dem Detroit Techno Sampler aus dem Jahr 96, der einfach heißt Detroit Beyond the Third Wave oder Age? Und vorhin haben wir was gehört, was ich wirklich sehr sehr oft und immer wieder gerne mitbringe. Das gibt zwei Doppel-CD Sampler vom Label Mo Wax, was vielen Leuten, die sich mit elektronischer Musik beschäftigen, ganz bestimmt was sagt. Und von denen gibt es diese zwei Sampler jeweils, zwei CDs, die einfach nur HAD heißen. Dann übrigens mit Z hinten und da sind wir dann wieder bei der Verbindung von elektronischer Musik zum Internet, denn so wie Leute, die geklaute Software tauschen, diese Software dann nicht Wares mit S hinten nennen, sondern Wares mit Z. Ich glaube, das ist einfach, weil das S halt ein weiches S ist, so wie das Z einfach ein anderer Buchstabe ist. Und das Z sieht ein bisschen fieser aus.
Genau, Serial Zorro. Genau, Serials.
Hups, neun Stücke sind da nur drauf, ne? Tim hat was. Er probiert es gleich nochmal mit seinem Mac.
Die menschlichen Programmer haben uns nie erkannt, das Jahr 2000 zu erkennen.
Da kann man ruhig einen Satz sagen, das ist ein Apple Dabespot. Wer jemals 2001 im Original gesehen hat, der hat die Stimme erkannt, das ist Hal, der Computer in diesem Spielfilm, den glaube ich viele Leute kennen.
Das ist aber nicht der Originalsprecher.
Aber er ist ziemlich angewandt.
Er ist eh nicht, aber der ist jetzt zu alt.
Hal, meine Lieblingsgeschichte, warum heißt Hal Hal? Weil eigentlich IBM vorher die Computer geliefert hat für diesen Film. Dann haben sie festgestellt, dass der Computer nicht so richtig gut wegkommt in dem Film. Und dann haben sie halt ihren Sponsoring-Deal zurückgezogen. Und dann hat die produzierende Firma gesagt, gut, dann nennen wir, dann heißen die Computer bei uns nicht IBM, sondern HAL, was alles genau ein Buchstaben vor IBM ist.
Und dann heißt der eben Hal.
Und, Entschuldigung, und diese Stimme von Hal sagt in diesem neuen Apple-Spot, redet halt über das Jahr 2000-Problem und sagt, ja Dave, das war ein Computerbug, das war ein Fehler im Betriebssystem, das tut uns leid und ich fühle mich jetzt viel besser, dass ich das jetzt sagen kann. Und nur McIntosh war McIntosh dafür bekannt, dass das jetzt vierstellige Jahresziffern benutzt haben, schon immer und deswegen mit dem Jahr 2000-Problem kann keines haben. Und du magst deinen McIntosh jetzt bestimmt viel mehr als mich, Dave oder Dave, hörst du mich Dave?
Dave ist halt schon längst weg.
Muss man ein bisschen erklären, weil Englisch oder...
Die Sachen mit dem McIntosh habe ich rausgenommen, weil die war eigentlich nicht so wichtig in dem Zusammenhang. Aber dass Hell irgendwie nochmal zu uns sprechen wird in dem Zusammenhang, das kann ich mir schon sehr gut vorstellen.
Jahr 2000.
Im Moment hören wir übrigens die Elektronauten aus Berlin vom Album Collective Induced Fiction. So viel dazu und wir telefonieren noch ein bisschen weiter. Oh, gleich gibt es einen Fritz Kurz Info. Dann telefonieren wir erstmal nicht, sondern machen in einer Minute das Info und dann telefonieren wir noch ein bisschen.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünder, dann 100, 1.
0, 30.
Personal, die Berliner SPD hat Umweltsenator Strider zum neuen Landesvorsitzenden gewählt. Er rief die Partei zur Geschlossenheit auf, um die große Koalition abzulösen. Strider war vom SPD-Spitzenkandidaten Momper vorgeschlagen worden.
Beide wollen nach der Abgeordnetenhauswahl im Oktober an den rot-grünen Senat bilden. Mahnung, in Berlin-Pankow haben am Abend rund 1000 Menschen mit einer Lichterkette der Opfer des Nationalsozialismus gedacht. Zugleich protestierten sie gegen das Vorhaben der Republikaner, ihre Bundesgeschäftsstelle in einer ehemaligen jüdischen Villa einzurichten.
Abstimmung, das Amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen US-Präsident Clinton geht weiter. Der US-Senat beschloss die Vernehmung von Zeugen.
Die republikanische Mehrheit lud unter anderem Monika Lewinsky zu einer Befragung vor. Unfall. Vor der Nordseeinsel Norderney sind zwei Tornadoflugzeuge der Bundeswehr zusammengestoßen und ins Meer gestürzt. Zwei Besatzungsmitglieder wurden verletzt, begreifen, zwei Geloten werden noch vermisst. Vorfall.
Im Jemen sind erneut mehrere Deutsche verschleppt worden.
Es handelt sich offenbar um eine Entwicklungshelferin und ihre Familie. Das Auswärtige Amt erklärte, man habe noch keinen Kontakt mit den Entführern.
In dieser Nase hast du uns zeitweise Schneefärbewerten zwischen 0 und minus 2 Grad.
Am Tag hat er erneut Schnee bei 1 bis 4 Grad.
Wir haben keine Meldungen weiter, nur eine gute Fahrt. Das war Matthias Kalkofer mit dem 40 Kurzinfo.
Live in Berlin. Freitag.
29.
Januar im Knackloch.
Die letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio ist angebrochen. Das bedeutet dann meistens, dass wir alle schon ein bisschen langsam so zum Ende der Sendung kommen, von der Konzentration her, dass man sich gerne mal dann auch über was anderes unterhält. Mir ist gerade auf dem Klo noch was eingefallen. Das ist schön.
Das war auch mal die besten Sachen.
Was für uns so selbstverständlich ist, dass es uns bei der Wendungsvorbereitung überhaupt nicht in den Sinn gekommen ist. Und zwar fragte mich mein Onkel neulich, was der und der Rechner wohl so kostet und ich meinte 2K und der guckte mich völlig entgeistert an und fragte sich, was ich jetzt wohl damit meinen könnte. Also die Abkürzung K für Kilo und die Verwendung von Kilo für 1000 im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch wird sich wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwie im Real Life durchsetzen. Das hab ich so, das kennt man jetzt schon auch, das Kost 2K oder irgendwie.
Y2K-Bug.
Ich hab mal jemand gefragt, was er für sein Programm bekommen hat und der meinte zu mir, ja 0, 6 Kilo D-Mark.
Das ist dann aber schon fast eklig oder?
Ich fand das sehr informativ, also vorrangig.
Es gibt einen anderen Interessenbereich, der auch viel mit Abkürzung und zwar extrem viel mit Abkürzung arbeitet, ist der ganze Finanzbereich. Ich glaub da hat man eigentlich, findet man, was ähnliches vor. Ich glaub wenn du dich mit Leuten, die sich viel mit Finanzen und Wirtschaft beschäftigen unterhältst, verstehst du kein Wort.
Das sind immer diese komischen Zeiten in der Zeitung.
Auch die Mediziner.
Abgesehen jetzt von den Aktienindexen und so.
Hat ja auch immer Gründe.
Man möchte sich auf der einen Seite präzise unterhalten, man möchte auf der anderen Seite sich von den anderen abheben. Man will ja auch gar nicht, dass die mithören können. Geht es darum?
Also bei Ärzten geht es ganz bestimmt darum.
Da will man einfach den Patienten klar machen, hier ich bin hier leer in weiß und ich sag dir was Sache ist und du verstehst die ganzen Worte nicht. Es kommt ja auch so ein bisschen aus der Kirche, da haben die in Latein gepredigt und kein einziger von den Leuten, die da unten saßen, hat ein Wort von denen verstanden, was die da gesagt haben. Es klang irgendwie göttlich, irgendwie wie aus einer anderen Welt und es muss wohl stimmen. So, was die da gesagt haben, keine Ahnung. Dieses Latein hat sich in der Medizin durchaus bis heute so gehalten und Latein, also wer Latein spricht, der gilt als gebildet. Und das hat schon natürlich Wirkung für Autorität, für Sachverstand.
Weil heutzutage ja so ist, dass man Englisch sprechen muss, um als gebildet zu gelten und auch eigentlich ohne Englisch ist es auf dem Computer- und Internetsektor sehr, sehr viel schwerer.
Nee, das ist klar, aber bei Ärzten, klar Ärzte können beim Internet auch nicht wirklich dann mit ihrer Sprache mitreden, auch nicht in Latein, das ist klar. Aber es geht um die Mechanismen, die da dahinter stehen und die sind davon sehr ähnlich, glaube ich schon. Ich würde sagen, bis ein Uhr, bis hier der Night Flight mit Martin Pedershoff beginnt, können wir noch ein bisschen telefonieren. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Hallo? Jo, du bist dran.
Also ich habe eine Frage, was heißt EBG beim Chatten?
Das habe ich nicht so ganz geblickt.
teufelsches großes Grinsen, weil man dazu sagen muss, dass bei den Amis ein Evil Grin eher so ein, das ist nicht böse gemeint, sondern das kann so ein verschmitztes Grin sein. Ja, verschmitzt.
Also bei den Amis, das verschmitzt dann schon Evil.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, was NT wirklich heißt?
Neandertal Technology.
Ach du, du bist ja auch gerade im Aussterben.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen...
Ich muss nochmal drüber nachdenken, sonst versau ich die Türen, aber ich häckle ihnen gleich nochmal.
Wie viele Glühbirnen braucht...
Wie viele Software-Programmierer braucht man, um eine Glühbirne zu wechseln? Ja, ist ein Hardware-Problem. Aber wie viele Techniker braucht man, um eine Glühbirne auszuwechseln? Auch keinen. Ja, weil es nach den Messgeräten alles in Ordnung ist, muss sich also nur um ein Software-Problem handeln.
Ok, jetzt habe ich es. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Microsoft und Jurassic Park? Das eine ist ein großer Vergnügungspark, in dem lauter Dinosaurier arbeiten, und das andere ist ein Film von Steven Spielberg.
Wie viele Microsoft-Programmierer brauchen wir, um Glühbirne zu wechseln?
Keine Ahnung.
Auch keine, die erklären die Dunkelheit zum Industriestandard. Der Typ, der vorher angerufen hat, mit dem, wie man einen Elefanten jagt. Wenn er mich hört, schreib mir in mein Gästebuch, wenn du einen Internetanschluss hast, wo ich das finde, unter www.ansi.nodrix.de Ansi wie A-N-S-I?
Ja, wie der Ansiestandard.
Du wirst doch mal mit Alter Vista, irgendwie Elefanten, Witt, Afrika, See, Kobold. Ich hab vorhin eine ASCII-Tabelle gesucht, auf meiner Platte war keine. Dann hab ich es über Yahoo probiert, im Direktoriet, da war alles nur Müll, ASCII-Charts ohne dieses Ackzeichen. Dann hab ich es mit Alter Vista probiert, in dem ich einfach alle ASCII-Zeichen eingegeben habe, die mir gerade einfielen, die Abkürzungen. Und dann habte ich sofort den passenden Link.
Ja, ich find's halt nur nervig, wenn ich ungefähr 6, 5 Millionen Hits habe.
Dann zuchtest du nicht.
Dann noch mal kurz deine URL bitte, www.ansi.nodrix.de.
N-O-T-R-I-X Punkt D-E Punkt D-E Ach, das ist ja falsch.
Das war der letzte Versuch.
Ah, la.
Das ist deine Homepage?
Du sagst, es ist Zeit nochmal mit alter Vesta zu gehen.
Ja, meine Gästebuch ist http//ansi.notrix.de//gb.cgi Okay, na gut.
Es ist was anderes. Der wird sich irgendwie kriegen.
Hast du nicht eine E-Mail-Adresse?
Ja, ich würde sagen, nicht so einfach.
Vielleicht ist es über E-Mail leichter. Dann noch mal E-Mail-Adresse. Sag dir nicht, du kriegst 200 Millionen Mails.
Ich freue mich über 200 Millionen Mails.
Eine Leute hier hat aufgerufen.
Noch. 54ps.gmx.de 54ps.gmx.de Alles klar, weiter Bescheid. Schönen Abend noch.
Aber nette Witze.
54ps, das ist doch ein Akronym-Frieg.
Hier ist Chaosradio.
Zu spät. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Robert, hallo.
Robert, hast du immer abkürzt?
Ja, hey, Mann, cool.
Ja, ich wollte einfach mal ein paar Wörter in den Raum werfen. Ich hab mir vorhin die Meinung der Angehörten von dem einen Chaos Computer Mitglied zu den gequackten Games, zu den Kids, die er da geurteilt hat, und fand ich gar nicht so korrekt.
Hey, da hat sie nicht verurteilt, sondern hat nur gesagt, dass das reine Wares-Tauschen nicht wirklich beliebt bei Hackern ist.
Na ja, das ist aber eine falsche Aussage.
Dieses Ganze mit dem Abkürzungen und so weiter kommt meiner Meinung nach aus dieser Mailbox-Szene. Und die Mailbox-Szene gibt es seit ein paar Jahren leider nicht mehr so. Wo es halt alles noch ohne Internet abging. Und da ging es hauptsächlich um gequackte Games. Die Leute haben sich die Abkürzung ausgedacht, um sich zu schützen.
Das ist mir bewusst. Ich habe auch gar nichts dagegen gesagt.
Ich würde sie gar nicht als Kids verzeichnen, weil da gibt es Leute, die machen die Sachen mit ihren Vätern zusammen. Und die machen das schon seit 10 Jahren oder so.
Wie lange machst du denn das schon?
Seit 13 Jahren oder so.
Seit 13 Jahren? Wie alt bist du denn?
23. Nein, also ich nähe allgemein Freak-Posteln, also nicht Cracken oder sonstige Sachen. Also früher war ich da mehr drin in der Szene, weil da war so noch die Bernähe auf der Amiga oder so, da Partys halt in Dänemark, wo sich so 4000 Leute zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester mal treffen und Wettkämpfe im Coden und Hacken und so abhalten halt.
Du hast ja auch sicher gehört, was Tim noch angefügt hat, nachdem er das gesagt hat. Ja, es geht auch wirklich nicht darum, irgendjemanden zu diskreditieren. Aber es gibt halt wirklich einzelne abgeschlossene Szenen, wo du sagst, stimmt komplett das?
Ja, ich denke halt, also eure Sendung ist voll okay und ich hab auch dazu auch neun Sachen schon erfahren. Und ich find doch geil, was für Know-how da ist. Aber ich denke halt, es ist halt auch zum Teil beschränkt, weil dieses ganze Computerding gerade, was im Untergrund abläuft, ist noch viel größer, als ihr es anschneidet habt.
Ja, aber ich verstehe das nicht falsch.
Es gibt diese ganzen Leute, die Demos programmieren ohne Ende und 4K-Intros, dann gibt es diese An-Sie-Szenen, die machen halt nur An-Sie-Art. Und da gibt es so viele Sachen, da kann man noch so viel drüber sagen, ohne immer dieses Hacken. Ihr habt halt immer dieses Hacken drin. Und es gibt halt aber so viele andere Sachen, die man noch anschneiden könnte auch mal in der Sendung.
Das stimmt, aber die Sendung hat halt jedes Mal auch ein anderes Thema. Übrigens wird die Zahl der Joints, die du wahrscheinlich geraucht hast, im Internet-Chat hier bei Fritz gerade auf 30 geschätzt.
Also nur mal so als Information.
Wenn das 30 im Leben waren, wären das nicht so viele. Ich würde sagen, du kontaktest uns mal und vielleicht machen wir eine Sendung zusammen, wenn du Bock hast.
Ja, vielleicht noch was dazu zu sagen. Beim Hacken geht es eigentlich im Grunde genommen, wenn man sich das von ganz vorne anguckt, um eine gewisse Geisteshaltung, eine Einstellung, einen Bewusstseinszustand, der durch die totale Konzentration auf das Problem gekennzeichnet ist. Ob man jetzt irgendwie Demos codet oder ob man irgendwie Exploits schreibt oder Software schreibt, ob man vielleicht mit Fingerabdruckscannern rumbastelt. Also egal, was man macht, solange das irgendwie kreativ ist, solange das Spaß macht und solange man die ganze Zeit auf der Suche nach der Lösung ist, diese Energie, die da im Raum ist, wenn man sowas tut. Das ist, worum es eigentlich geht. Und das gibt es natürlich auch in anderen Szenen. Und was vielleicht die etwas abfälligen Bemerkungen über Rare-Dudes verursacht, sind halt Leute, denen es tatsächlich bloß darum geht, ich will die meisten Spiele haben. Das ist einfach keine Herausforderung drin. Das ist uninteressant. Und die Leute, die Demos schreiben, die sind tatsächlich Leute, die kreativ tätig sind, die man auch wirklich bewundern kann, was sie zustande bringen, weil sie sich so lange mit dem Problem auseinandersetzen, noch mal ein Byte rauskitzeln, noch mal ein Byte rauskitzeln, bis irgendwie ihre 3D-Animation in 4 Kilo Byte reinpasst. Das finde ich gut.
Da geht es um Nano-Sekunden und das ist große Klasse.
Aber das ist auch Hacking im eigentlichen Sinne.
Das Guff ist, andere Leute Kreativität benutzen, um daraus einer Sammlerleidenschaft nachzugehen oder um irgendwas Verbotenes zu tun. Das kann man machen. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Free Climbing und Bungee Jumping. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen, wenn ich als Alter sage, mit Mitte 30 irgendwie, es ist wirklich dieses Ding mal einen Kaugummiautomaten knacken oder kein Ahnen, es ist genau dasselbe, nur in digitale Bereiche übertragen. Ich glaube, dass es eine Zeitlang eine super Faszination hat, Waves zu tauschen.
Das haben wir ja auch alle gemacht. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir das nicht selber durchlebt haben. Die Mailbox-Szene und so, natürlich hat sich dieser ganze Slang in der Mailbox-Szene auch entwickelt. Es gibt diese Abkürzungen, die wir vorhin hervorgehoben haben, die durch diese Chat-Systeme aufgekommen sind. Aber das ist auch nur ein Teil. Es gibt eben auch einen großen Slang-Bereich, der eben aus der ganzen Hacker-Kultur an sich, die im Prinzip die gesamte Computer-Kultur einschließt. Wir verstehen das Wort Hacker nicht als die Gruppe, die durch Datennetze surft und Rechner aufmacht. Das ist das, was die Zeitungen schreiben. Das ist aber einfach nicht der Punkt. Das Hacking an sich ist einfach eine Einstellung, die man finden kann, die sich an Kreativität und Originalität orientiert. Der kreative Umgang mit den Dingen einfach. Genau.
Hacken macht glücklich. Kreativer Umgang mit Technologie. Fünf Freunde wollen mit dem Auto zum Seewitz fahren. Wir kamen gerade ein netter Witz im Chat. Fünf Freunde wollen mit dem Auto zum Seewitz fahren. Sie steigen ein, aber das Auto startet nicht. Mehrere Versuche scheitern. Dann kommt der Vorschlag des Computerfreaks. Vielleicht werden wir alle aussteigen und wieder einsteigen? Wir buchen mal.
Das geht eigentlich anders, ne?
Das ist die Sache mit den Bugs.
Guter Punkt.
Es gibt ja da verschiedene Bugs. Auch da hat das Jargon-Fall eine schöne Unterscheidung. Also Bug generell ist halt der Fehler im Programm. Und im Jargon-Fall finden sich dann noch so Beschreibungen für bestimmte Arten von Programmen. Da ist zum Beispiel der Mandel-Bug zu erwähnen. Der Mandel-Bug, man ahnt schon die Nähe zu dem Wort Mandelbrot-Set, ist halt so dermaßen komplex und obskur, dass er völlig nicht-deterministisch, unvorhersagbar auftritt und man einfach überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit hat, ihn irgendwie zu finden.
Ein Mandel-Bug ist ein Bug, mit dem man halt leben muss.
Naja, aber auf jeden Fall ein Mandel-Bug ist immer auch ein Bohr-Bug. Ein Bohr-Bug ist es nämlich dann, wenn er sich unter bestimmten, wenn er sich sozusagen wiederholen lässt. Und man ihn, also, nein, jetzt hab ich es aufeinander gehört. Ein Bohr-Bug ist auf jeden Fall ein Bug, der sich sozusagen unter gegebenen Bedingungen immer wieder wiederholen lässt. Der so irgendwie physikalisch erklärbar ist. Was wiederum das Gegenteil von einem Heisen-Bug ist. Ein Heisen-Bug ist ein Bug, der sich halt in dem Moment, wo man ihn versucht zu finden, irgendwie entzieht und nicht mehr auftritt. Diese Heisen-Bergschwer-Unschärf-Relation, das irgendwie, das Suchen nach dem Symptom sozusagen, das Symptom entfernt. Und dann gibt es noch den Schröding-Bug, nach der Schrödinger Katze-Geschichte. Das ist irgendwie ein Bug, der überhaupt nicht auftritt, solange bis sich irgendjemand mal das Programm anguckt und feststellt, dass er drin ist.
Und in dem Moment, wo er ihn gefunden hat, ab dem Moment tritt er permanent auf und irgendwie muss entfernt werden, bevor das Programm wieder funktionieren kann.
Wir versuchen wieder einen schnellen Durchlauf, das heißt jetzt bitte nur noch Anrufer, die wirklich irgendwie, was weiß ich nicht, noch eine Abkürzung haben, die sie erfragen wollten. Kurze Microsoft-Witze nehmen wir natürlich auch immer noch gerne, aber wirklich kurze Durchläufe, also keine längeren Fragen. Auch die von Apple. Ja, wir nehmen auch Apple-Witze natürlich. Wir nehmen auch Linux-Witze, wenn es solche gäbe. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ah gut, ich habe mir gerade eine grundlegende Frage eingefallen.
Ist da eine Frage an Unix?
Aber das ist wiederum bemerkenswert. Unix ist wiederum ein Witz auf den Namen Multics. Multics war ein Betriebssystem, das bei AT&T gebraucht war. Und die Saga geht, dass die ursprünglichen Autoren von Unix ein Betriebssystem ohne Zeitabrechnung brauchten, damit sie was war das Programm damals, irgendein Spiel spielen konnten. Ich glaube, Lunar Lander, Lunar Lander, irgendwie sowas. Die Netzwerkanbindung überhaupt nicht. Aber bemerkenswert ist halt dieses X am Ende. Und vor allen Dingen der Plural, der Plural von Unix ist nämlich Unixen. Und nicht Unixe, oder wie man das mal empfindet. Oder auch Unices. Oder auch Unices, genau. Und dieses X ans Ende zu tun, ist dann halt aus dieser Unix-Geschichte entstanden, weil dann verschiedene Klons von Unix rauskamen. Die Ultricks und Minis am Ende heißt halt Unix-Kompatibilität. So ist der Name Linux aufzustanden gekommen. Das Betriebssystem von Linux ist Unix-Kompatibilität. Eine gute gibt es glaube ich nicht.
Schade.
Also es gibt einige, probier einfach ein paar aus. Die meisten erfüllen eigentlich deine Anforderungen, aber es gibt noch keine gute.
Ach so, das ist so ein Programm, mit dem man Mail abholen kann und die bleibt auf dem Server.
Und Fein, Fein kann noch iMap, oder?
Man muss nur die richtige Frage stellen, schon so ein Alarm zu röbeln.
Nee, willst du einen Server?
Ähm, kurz noch aus dem Chat, das schreit hier die ganze Zeit schon rum, wofür steht C I H?
Keine Ahnung, das ist doch dieser Virus, oder?
Steht glaube ich im Jargonfile.
Nee, steht nicht im Jargonfile.
Steht nicht drin.
Ist auch ein Virus, scheinbar.
Keine Ahnung.
Gut, wissen wir nicht. Ha ha ha, damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet. Nee, nee. Gut, dann machen wir mal Schluss mit den Anrufen jetzt.
Die Sprache entwickelt sich schleudigst weiter. Auch das Jargon-File hat viele Worte, die jetzt gängig gelten, nicht drin. So Bogomips ist zum Beispiel so ein Wort. Bogomips, das ist diese Performance-Anzeige, die Linux anzeigt, wenn es bootet. Dieser Computer hat so und so viele Bogomips, er kann so eine einfache Rechenschleife so und so schnell ablaufen. Sagt nicht wirklich was für die Geschwindigkeit aus, aber ist schon wieder ein religiöses Item für sich.
Ab einem es geht weiter hier mit dem Night Flight. Wird es schon wieder rum? Und ich hab ehrlich gesagt, bei dem Thema der Sendung, als ihr gesagt habt, es geht um Hacker-Slang, da hab ich ein bisschen gedacht, na drei Stunden ist doch lange, vielleicht wird knapp, wir müssen schieben oder so, aber überhaupt nicht, war locker. Könnte man sicher noch länger drüber reden. Ich glaube wir haben ganz viele Abkürzungen. Nicht gesagt, das gibt es aber und das ist natürlich immer der generelle Tipp. Ich krieg viele E-Mails und ich weiß, ich krieg die E-Mails, die an diese Sendung gehen, chaos.orb.de übrigens, die E-Mailadresse für diese Sendung, die an alle verteilt wird, die hier beteiligt sind. Und ich lese die auch und es gibt ganz viele Leute, die immer fragen, wo finde ich dies und das, das größte Problem am Internet. Aber man kann nur sagen, lernt ein bisschen mit den Suchmaschinen umgehen. Und wenn ihr zum Beispiel wissen wollt, wofür diese ganzen Abkürzungen stehen, es gibt massig Fals im Netz, wo erklärt ist die ganzen Emotikons, die ganzen Abkürzungen. Man muss ein bisschen suchen, eine Viertelstunde Zeit mal nehmen, dann findet man das auch alles und vielleicht kriegen wir ja auch für den Chaos-Ticker ein paar Links zusammen. Und fragt uns bitte nicht mehr, wie man Hacker wird. Hacker wird man selber. Das ist wirklich eine super häufig gestellte Frage per E-Mail. Am besten auch ohne Hallo und ohne Tschüss, sondern... Man geht mit der Axt in den Wald und...
Wie werde ich Hacker?
Der Coolness-Faktor ist halt irgendwie stark gestiegen bei dem Wort. Aber im Prinzip Hacker... Hacker wird man wirklich von alleine, dadurch, dass man sich einfach mit Dingen beschäftigt. Und das hat, wie gesagt, das kann man gar nicht oft genug betonen, nichts mit Computern zu tun.
In diesem Sinne, viel Spaß am Gerät.